Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Blue Moon. Genauer gesagt zum Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Am letzten Donnerstag jeden ungeraden Monats findet es hier statt. Ansonsten woanders. Herzlich willkommen dazu. Und was bedeutet das? Es bedeutet, dass Leute vom Chaos Computer Club, den habt ihr vielleicht schon mal von gehört oder ja, betriebsnahe Personen nennt man das glaube ich in anderen Umständen auch, hierher kommen und etwas über Dinge erzählen, die mit diesem großen, weiten Internet oder Computern oder digitalen Netzpolitik zu tun haben und wollen sich heute einem ganz besonderen Thema widmen, denn es ist ja nicht nur so, dass das weit verbreitete Geschehe vom HKD immer nur vor seinem Rechner oder seiner Lötplatine oder seinem was auch immer technischen Gerät hängt. Nein, die versammeln sich auch und laden dann auch noch alle anderen ein und das nennt man dann Chaos Communication Congress. Das ist eine riesige Veranstaltung, die nicht wie viele andere Veranstaltungen dieser Art irgendwie einfach bezahlt wird. Also da geht jemand hin, wirft einen Koffer mit Geld auf den Tisch und sagt hier, mach mal bitte Großveranstaltung, sondern das wird auch organisiert von den Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club. Das heißt, die wissen, wie man sowas macht. Und das wollen wir heute mal genauer erzählen. How to make a Congress, wie man eine Hacker Großveranstaltung produziert, das wird heute hier das Thema in den nächsten zwei Stunden sein, wo auch ihr gefragt seid, falls ihr schon mal auf einem Chaos Communication Congress wart, vielleicht sogar auf dem letzten und dazu eine lustige Anekdote zu erzählen habt oder einfach mal loswerden wollt, wie es war oder Fragen an die ihr macht habt, dann könnt ihr heute hier anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. So, wie gesagt, da sind die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club im Studio. Wir fangen mal an, die vorzustellen. Das sind heute Erdgeister und Guten Tag.
Hallo.
Der Danimo?
Schönen guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend und der Starbuck.
Und der Profi.
Der Profi.
Also du hier mit irgendwie, du hast schon wieder vergessen anzuschalten, den Kroos.
Wenn ihr es nicht gesagt hättet, wär es keinem aufgefallen, das ist das Schöne bei Radiophilien.
Wir haben schon dreimal Hallo gesagt.
Ach, jetzt hör aber auf. So, für den unwahrscheinlichen Fall, dass da draußen jemand sitzt, der sich denkt, so Chaos Communication Congress hab ich schon mal gehört, aber so richtig genau was das ist, weiß ich nicht. Was ist denn das so genau?
Na, da kommen ganz viele Nerds zusammen aus allen möglichen Themenbereichen, weil, wie du schon gesagt hast, die Hacker, die mit ihrem Computer rumlerden, sind ja nur ein Teil der weltweiten Nerdsphäre, wo es wie Kulturnerds und Büchernerds und Kaffee-Nerds gibt. Und die haben erkannt, dass die Computernerds sich da eine Nische geschaffen haben, in der man einander auf Augenhöhe begegnen kann zum Erfahrungsaustausch. Und haben eine nicht-kommerzielle, ziemlich coole Veranstaltung mit angeschlossener Party und Vorträgen aus dem Boden gestampft. Seit jetzt 31 Jahren, wo sich einfach lohnt mitzumachen und wo man immer mit Wissensgewinn rausgeht.
Also angefangen hat es ja tatsächlich als reine Nerd-Veranstaltung, also wirklich so, weiß nicht wie viel, aber das erste Mal da waren vielleicht 100 oder so, wie gesagt 31 Jahre, das war irgendwann in den 80ern.
Da war keiner von uns dabei.
Da war auf jeden Fall keiner von uns dabei. Und wenn da Leute was mit Computern zu tun hatten, dann waren es halt wirklich so richtig die Hardcore-Nerds und sie saßen. Also da war gerade so die erste Zeit mit BTX und das erste Mal die Netze erforschen. Und da saßen halt wirklich nur Leute, die halt so richtig Hardcore-Computer-Nerds waren.
Weiß man auch, wann sich das geöffnet hat? Oder ist das so ein schleichender Prozess?
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein schleichender Prozess. Also wie gesagt, zum Anfang waren es vielleicht 100. Wir sind halt stetig größer geworden. Und ich glaube, so richtig geöffnet für alle. Also ich würde sagen, Hamburg war so ein großer Schnitt. Also wir sind ja vor drei Jahren nach Hamburg umgezogen, weil es in Berlin zu klein war.
Nachdem wir vorher in Hamburg, ganz, ganz früher auch in Hamburg waren.
Das Problem in Berlin war, dass die Leute, die kommen wollten, nicht mehr reingepasst haben. Und da war das mit der Eröffnung hin oder her ziemlich schwer, Leute davon zu überzeugen, auf diese Veranstaltung überhaupt zu kommen. Und selbst wenn man sie überzeugt hat, war kein Platz. Und jetzt erst mit dem großen Haus in Hamburg, wo wir hingezogen sind, ins CCH, hat sich das wirklich dann so ergeben, dass wir auch allen anderen Nerdkulturen uns gegenüber öffnen konnten.
Also nicht nur Nerdkulturen, sondern auch wirklich interessierten Normalbürgern, sag ich mal. Also halt früher war es wirklich so ein familiäres, die Nerds treffen sich einmal im Jahr. Also man kannte sich halt irgendwie so aus dem Chat oder woher auch immer. Und dann hat man sich halt ein Jahr im Jahr getroffen, hat irgendwie ein paar Vorträge gehalten, aber irgendwie eigentlich ist man hingefahren, um irgendwie miteinander zu quatschen. Und halt so in den letzten paar Jahren ist es halt so geworden, dass hauptsächlich Vorträge für viele in den Forderungen gestellt wurden. Also wir haben halt ein großes Vortragsprogramm, vier Slots mit irgendwie acht Vorträgen pro Tag.
Ja, insgesamt über 100 Vorträge.
Über 100 Vorträge und halt wirklich dann auch ansprechen, die normalen Leute da draußen.
Die sind also willkommen, sollen gerne kommen. Und es gibt dann Vorträge und es gibt eine angeschlossene Party. Ich vermute mal, es handelt sich dabei um eine klassische Party mit Musik und da wird auch alkoholisches Getränk ausgeschenkt. Was gibt es denn noch?
Na, es gibt noch selbst organisierte Workshops, wo jeder sich eintragen kann und wenn er mit Gleichgesinnten an irgendwas basteln möchte, kann er da einfach sein Kram mitbringen und da basteln.
Also es gibt einmal wirklich so Workshops in Workshop-Räumen, die dann für ein spezielles Thema sind. Und dann gibt es das große, was früher das Hackcenter war und wir es jetzt heutzutage in Assemblies umgenannt haben, also wo so Einzelgruppen, die sich entweder zusammen treffen, weil sie halt lokal zusammengehören, also irgendwie die Airfarkreise oder Chaos-Treffs.
Das sind, muss man wissen, lokale Subgruppierungen des Chaos-Computer-Clubs sozusagen, wo die sich in einer Stadt zusammenfinden.
Aber nicht mal zwangsweise vom Club. Der Kongress ist auf jeden Fall inzwischen auch so weit offen, dass er nicht nur Club-Nerds anzieht, sondern auch, wenn sich Leute einen gewissen Thema widmen. Wir hatten zum Beispiel das Assembly, die Koch-Nerds, die haben dann wirklich Kühlschränke und Kochplatten mitgebracht und haben dann drei Tage lang gekocht.
Okay, also alles, was man irgendwie nerden kann, wird dann auch da durchgeführt. Es gibt auch die großen Höhepunkte, immer so Vorträge, die man auch in den Medien findet. Dieses Jahr war das Starbucks-Vortrag über die Biometrie, wo man Fingerabdrücke fälschen kann, per Foto. Und dann war ganz groß der Schlagzeilen, das habt ihr euch auch gehört, von wie kaputt UMTS eigentlich ist.
SS7.
Das sind Details.
Aber wir haben ja eigentlich, oder wir sind selbst in unseren Kreisen davon ausgedrückt, mit diesem GSM ist eigentlich alles ganz furchtbar, aber UMTS ist vielleicht nicht ganz so kaputt. Und das ist heute, das ist auf diesem Congress einmal komplett ins Gegenteil verkehrt worden.
Aber darüber wollen wir heute gar nicht so genau reden, sondern wie man so eine Großveranstaltung macht. Wie viele Leute waren das noch mal? Ich meine, ich hätte irgendwas von 10.000 gelesen. Über was?
Über 10.000.
Über 10.000. Aha, die offizielle Zahl.
Also ich denke mal, es wird eher so Richtung 11.000, 12.000 gegangen sein. Also es soll mal die Frage, was du als Tages-Tickets, aber Besucher oder separat verkaufte und verteilte Tickets waren auf jeden Fall deutlich über 10.000.
Verstehe. Da ist ja die Frage, wann fängt man denn an, so ein Kongress zu organisieren?
Wann geht das überhaupt los?
Was?
Moment mal, wieso das denn? Nee, nee, jetzt ist noch Nachbereitung. Also ich mein, so richtig los geht's halt so langsam im Sommer. Also je nachdem, also ob es jetzt zum Beispiel ein neues Gebäude gibt oder das gleiche Gebäude, aber du musst dich halt schon mal mit den Leuten vom Haus treffen und halt irgendwie mal klarmachen, wir wollen auch wirklich wieder zu euch kommen. Und dann gibt's halt irgendwie so ein paar Gespräche. Aber so richtig los geht's, ich sag mal so September, Oktober, naja September, also wo dann halt, dann ist halt auch klar, wir machen wieder ein Kongress, wir machen es wieder in Hamburg zum Beispiel oder wo auch immer. Und dann fangen halt so die Einzelgruppen so langsam an, sich mit ihren Themen zu beschäftigen. Und das werden wir heute auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen ausführen.
Und was genau oder, nee andersrum, wer genau ist das? Also wer setzt sich da hin und fängt an, dieses Ding zu organisieren?
Na, es gibt so eine Kern-Orga, die aus, naja, sagen wir grob, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht Leuten besteht. Die halt, wie gesagt, irgendwie, es gibt halt so ein paar Leute, die halt wirklich verantwortlich sind, das heißt, die in der GmbH angestellt sind, beziehungsweise halt für die GmbH dort Sachen machen, die halt auch unterschrieben. Ach so, na, wir haben, ich glaube, zum ersten Camp, also es gibt ja den CCCEV, also den Eingetragenen Verein. Und irgendwann, als wir die dumme Idee gehabt haben, das erste Mal ein Camp zu machen, wurde es halt einigen Leuten dann so ein bisschen wurmig und dachten, na ja, könnte ja in Zweifelzahl auch schiefgehen. Das heißt, wir gründen mal lieber eine Veranstaltungs-GmbH.
Camp ist sozusagen, muss man auch wieder erklären, ist sozusagen dasselbe wie der Kongress, nur im Freien und draußen und nicht so oft.
Nur alle vier Jahre.
Nur alle vier Jahre, genau.
Dieses Jahr übrigens wieder, aber kommen wir nachher bestimmt auch nochmal kurz dazu. Also wie gesagt, zu der Gelegenheit wurde die CCC Veranstaltungs-GmbH gegründet, die explizit dafür da ist, diese Veranstaltung zu organisieren. Und die hat natürlich auch Leute wie Prokuristen oder eine Angestellte haben wir sogar, eine Offizielle, die dafür bezahlt wird. Und die Leute müssen natürlich die ganzen offiziellen Sachen machen. Das heißt, die unterschreiben die Verträge mit dem Haus, die gucken halt, was man alles so braucht. Also von Hardware bis Netzwerk muss ja auch immer Sachen unterschrieben werden, Versicherung.
Und vor allem hältst du diesen Sack Flö zusammen, mal die Freiwilligen rechtzeitig aufzufordern, was zu tun, was sehr wichtig ist bei den Nerds.
Also, dass das schön ist, also die Gruppen, die wir nachher irgendwie alle noch so im Einzelnen mal ein bisschen ansprechen werden, sind halt wirklich sehr selbstständig. Das heißt, die machen das in der Regel auch schon eine Weile. Die wissen, wo es da Probleme gibt. Die wissen, was man letztes Jahr vielleicht nicht so gut gemacht hat, dass man das mal besser machen kann. Aber es muss halt immer so jemand geben, der die Obe auf sich hat. Das ist nicht zwangsweise dadurch, dass die sagen, du musst das jetzt anders machen. Sondern in der Regel kommen die Gruppen selber und sagen, wir würden das so machen, aber sie brauchen jemanden, der abnickt, der sagt, ja, mach mal so, das passt schon. Das braucht man halt einfach. Und du brauchst während der Veranstaltung auch diese Leute, die Ansprechpartner fürs Haus sind. Oder wenn die Polizei kommt, die so direkter Erstkontakt für die Außenstehenden zum Kongress sind.
Ihr habt die ganze Zeit gesagt, es gibt irgendwie eine Angestellte in dieser GmbH und es gibt ansonsten Freiwillige. Was heißt das? Wird das wirklich organisiert von Leuten, die das in ihrer Freizeit machen? Oder wie sieht das aus?
Komplett. Also wie gesagt, mit dieser eigenen Ausnahme gibt es halt eigentlich keinen von uns selber, der daraus finanziellen oder andersartigen Nutzen zieht.
Eher sogar noch im Gegenteil. Denn wir zahlen als diejenigen, die den Kongress mitorganisieren, ganz regulären Eintritt. Also es gibt halt noch irgendwie eine Rabattstaffel für Leute, die dem CCC angehören, die also Mitglieder sind. Aber ob man da jetzt zum Kongress selber beiträgt oder nicht, ist völlig unerheblich dabei.
Die einzigen, die nicht bezahlen, sind Speaker. Ansonsten bezahlt jeder da auch selbst die Engel.
Und das ist halt nicht nur eine Frage des Eintrittspreises, sondern tatsächlich, da gibt es Leute, die sich halt im Vorfeld über Wochen oder Monate wirklich halt den Arsch aufreißen und irgendwie Dinge für diesen Kongress tun und teilweise irgendwie deswegen nicht zur Arbeit gehen, also irgendwie keinen Job haben in der Zeit, sondern sich wirklich halt 100%ig den Kongress widmen.
Also das ist ganz schön heftig, sagen. Also das ist nicht nur so Freizeit, sondern es ist wirklich Arbeit. Also Arbeit, Arbeit. Jetzt viel gerade kurz das Wort Engel. Ich vermute nicht, dass sie einer religiösen Gemeinschaft plötzlich angehört, sondern...
Na, das ist schon eine religiöse Gemeinschaft.
Also neben dem Fakt, dass die Organisatoren kein Geld bekommen und das freiwillig machen, machen auch alle Aufgaben, die auf den Kongress so anfallen, werden halt von Freiwilligen gemacht. Also bei uns heißen sie Engel. Das ist irgendwie aus historischen Gründen irgendwann mal so erwachsen. Und da gibt es halt verschiedene. Es gibt Engel, die halt nachts an der Eingangstür stehen und irgendwie gucken, dass Leute nur mit Bändchen reinkommen. Dann gibt es Leute, die halt an der Kasse sitzen und Tickets verkaufen. Es gibt Engel, die die Kamera bewegen und Mikrofone rumreichen. Also alle diese Aufgaben, die halt normalerweise beim Kongress, der von einer Firma ausgerichtet wird, von bezahlten Kräften verrichtet werden würden.
Engel, die Engel für sorgen.
Wie können die Markus mal raten lassen, wie viele Leute da freiwillig Schichten fahren?
Bei was, 10.000 Besucher war es? Wie viele Tage geht der Kongress? Ich weiß nicht, 1.000?
Also es ist wirklich eine wirklich große Anzahl von Freiwilligen. Und in über die letzten Jahre ist es auch eher so, dass wir eigentlich schon fast zu viele Engel haben. Also die prügeln sich wirklich darum, dass sie irgendwie Schichten machen können. Und sie bezahlen tatsächlich noch einen normalen Eintritt. Also sie kriegen halt keine vergünstigen, sie kriegen halt ein T-Shirt nachher so als Dankssagung. Aber ansonsten ist es halt wirklich normaler Kongressbesucher. Sie knapsen sich Zeit ab, können nicht zu Vorträgen gehen oder so, um halt den Kongress überhaupt irgendwie am Laufen zu halten.
Jetzt gibt es ja sozusagen schon in der Vorbereitung, kann ich mir vorstellen, Sachen, die für großes Hallo und allgemeinen Diskussionsbedarf sorgen. Zum Beispiel, wie entscheidet man sich denn für ein Haus?
Da ist glaube ich der Umzug nach Hamburg ein sehr gutes Beispiel. Wir waren bis vor drei Jahren in Berlin, die letzten zehn Jahre praktisch in zwei Häusern. Einmal am Haus am Königischen Park vorher. Dann sind wir uns dann ins BCC umgezogen. Dann wurde irgendwann klar, dass dieses Haus zu klein wird. Wir haben die letzten zwei Jahre, als wir in Berlin waren, schon Tickets rationieren müssen. Wir hatten einen Pre-Sale, wo Leute zur richtigen Zeit auf den richtigen Button drücken mussten, um überhaupt noch ein Ticket zu kriegen.
Wir haben auch noch ein Schneeballsystem, wo Tickets eingeführt werden, das Engel und Vortragende des letzten Jahres bevorzugt werden. Aber so richtig schön war das nicht.
Auf jeden Fall war die Frage, was machen wir? Wollen wir weiter in der engen Gruppe bleiben oder weiter expandieren? Dann haben wir uns tatsächlich in einer mehr oder weniger großen Runde, ich glaube, das waren so 30, 40 Leute, die Interesse am Club oder am Kongress haben, zusammengesetzt und haben gesagt, was machen wir jetzt? Dann haben wir erst mal diskutiert, ob wir gleich bleiben wollen, in den Gebäuden oder größer werden. Dann kam irgendwann tatsächlich, McFly war es damals gewesen, der mehr oder weniger auch selbstständig nach Gebäuden gesucht hat, die cool sind. Zumindest aus meiner Sicht waren wir eigentlich alle eher dagegen zum Anfang, aber dann sind wir hingegangen und haben uns das Haus angeguckt. Das war auch so geile Scheiße. Wer noch nicht in Hamburg im CCH war zum Kongress, sollte das auf jeden Fall nächstes Jahr tun. Es war vom Anfang an nicht klar, ob wir das machen wollen, aber als wir das erste Mal da waren, waren alle uns begeistert.
Jetzt habt ihr euch dafür entschieden, das ist gut und schön, aber dann muss ja irgendjemand hingehen und sagen, du dürfen dieses riesige Gebäude haben für eine Woche.
Da braucht es schon ein bisschen Verhandlungsgeschick. Aber ich will voranstellen, es braucht erst mal ein Gebäude, wo alle reinkassen. Da sind die Gebäude in Deutschland langsam alle.
Da kommen wir gerade auf jeden Fall in Probleme. Das Haus in Hamburg ist bei 12.500 Leute zu. Dann ist es feuerpolizeilich einfach Ende. Da müssen wir jetzt mal sehen, wie das nächstes Jahr läuft. Und wie gesagt, auch größere Räumlichkeiten gibt es eigentlich nicht mehr wirklich immer.
Würdet ihr wirklich unbegrenzt weiter wachsen wollen?
Die Frage haben wir uns ja tatsächlich gestellt, als wir von Berlin nach Hamburg gegangen sind. Ich war auch damals so ein starker Verfechter des Nicht-Größer-Werns, weil ich auf der DEFCON zum Beispiel war, also auf den großen amerikanischen Hackerkonferenzen mit 10.000 Leuten und ich war wirklich angewidert. Also es war überhaupt nicht schön. Und ich hab auch nicht gedacht, dass wir es hinkriegen, aber wir haben es tatsächlich gut hinkriegt. Und ich sehe ehrlich gesagt noch Potenzial. Also wenn wir irgendwie Räumlichkeiten hätten, die größer wären, könnte man da auf jeden Fall noch gut. Lass mich noch eine Sache. Also wir haben einen ziemlich guten, also wir haben ja irgendwie, vom Camp haben wir in den letzten Stunden geredet. Also Camp ist mehr oder weniger noch viel selbstorganisierender als der Kongress. Das heißt, du hast halt wirklich die Einzelgruppen, die dort Villages heißen, die sich halt zusammenfinden und halt irgendwie selbstständig Dinge tun. Also hauptsächlich, sie teilen sich halt irgendwie ein Zelt, weil sie kennen sich, haben einen Bierkasten, um zusammen zu stehen. Und dieses Konzept dieser Villages, das war die gute Idee, das hat auf den Kongress übertragen. Das heißt, wir haben halt einfach wirklich dieses Hackcenter, was halt früher war Hackcenter. Das heißt, wir haben Tische und Strom hingestellt und haben gesagt, hier ist Hackcenter, setzt euch irgendwie hin und hackt einfach. Und jetzt ist es halt so geworden, dass man halt wirklich kleine Gruppen hat, die sich halt selbstständig irgendwie coole Hardware mitschleppen und irgendwie coole Dinge tun und halt, wie gesagt, eigentlich autonom agieren. Und das war, glaube ich, ein wirklich wichtiger Schritt, weil sonst kannst du einfach die Massen gar nicht mehr beherrschen. Aber dadurch, dass sie sich jetzt alle so in kleinen Gruppen selbst organisieren, klappt das halt irgendwie wunderbar. Und ich denke auch, da ist noch mehr Luft nach oben.
Okay, also wir halten mal fest bis jetzt, ein Team voller Freiwilligen, die das kostenlos machen und sogar noch Eintritt bezahlen, organisieren sich ein riesiges Haus, wo man Dinge rein tun kann. Das muss natürlich dann irgendwie voller Technik gestopft werden. Wer schon mal auf dem Chaos Communication Congress war, weiß, da liegen dann überall Kabel, es gibt irgendwie komische Rohre, durch die Rohrposten nach schief und schräg geschickt werden und ein eigenes Telefonsystem und so was. Das kennen wir aber alles noch nachher. Die weitere wichtige Frage ist ja, dass das Kernstück des Kongresses ist. Also viele Leute, die von außen sehen, sehen ja vor allen Dingen das, nämlich die Vorträge, die es da gibt. Das muss ja wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie organisiert werden. Wer macht das und wie geht das vonstatten?
Das ist genau so ein selbst organisiertes Team. Heißt Content Team. Das steht inzwischen aus fünf verschiedenen unabhängigen Teams, die sich jeweils einem bestimmten Track, also einem Themengebiet zuwenden. Und dann aus den Einreichungen, die von potenziellen Vortragenden gemacht werden, die besten aussuchen und die dann in einem Programm platzieren.
Ist das denn, aber ist das so, dass man jetzt da eher selber über 100 Vorträge sagt, muss man da irgendwie schon suchen und zusammenkratzen, sodass man auch irgendwie 100 Leute zusammenkriegt, die gerade zwischen den Jahren dann auch irgendwie sich die Zeit ans Bein binden wollen, um irgendwie Vorträge zu machen? Oder ist es eher so, ihr habt 5000 Einreichungen und alle sind übel launig, wenn sie abgelehnt werden?
Also ich glaube, wir hatten dieses Jahr so ungefähr 400 Einreichungen, von denen wir halt irgendwie knapp 100 genommen haben. Also das ist noch ein relativ guter Schnitt, wenn man so wissenschaftliche Konferenzen irgendwie im Gegenpart hat, wo halt irgendwie so 10 bis 15 Prozent Acceptance Rate ist. Aber es ist halt auch nicht so, als wenn das wir halt irgendwie alle nehmen. Also es ist in der Regel eher, dass ich, also es gab tatsächlich sogar schon Neugründungen von Veranstaltungen, die halt mit den Speakern, die bei uns abgelehnt wurden, dann halt ihr Programm gemacht haben.
Wobei es nicht mal heißt, dass es ein schlechter Vortrag ist. Sondern die Konkurrenz ist so riesig groß, dass man sich da nicht über den Kopf gestoßen fühlen muss, wenn man nicht genommen wird.
Aber wie wird denn das entschieden? Da stehen wir ja gerade vor, dass man auch hitzige Debatten führen kann.
Es ist genauso ein Vollzeitjob vorher. Da sitzen fünf Teams und machen da drei Monate lang eigentlich kaum was anderes als die Speaker müssen ja dann auch betüdelt werden. Da muss man Anreise planen, zum Teil Visa planen, zum Teil die Termine aus Baldova in Unterkunft irgendwie ranbekommen, schauen, wo die vielleicht bleiben können.
Also früher, bis vor drei Jahren glaube ich, war es so, dass tatsächlich, es gab dann halt immer so zwei, drei Termine vor dem Kongress, so auch angefangen im Oktober, September meistens schon. Also CFP, also der Call for Paper, war dann in der Regel so zum Sommer, haben wir es versucht. Also der Aufruf, Dinge einzureichen. Und dann gab es halt diese 300, 400 Einreichungen und dann haben sich halt 10, 15 Leute, was wir damals waren, oder noch ein bisschen mehr, haben sich dann hingesetzt und sich praktisch gegenseitig die Fresse eingeschlagen, wie ich will den Talk haben. Nee, der ist doof.
Das waren echt anstrengende Runden.
Also richtig mit Stoppuhr, zwei Minuten Zeit, was über den Vortrag zu sagen, danach wird abgestimmt oder geschoben. Also das war wirklich hart. Und jetzt irgendwie vor zwei Jahren haben wir umgestellt oder vor drei Jahren auf das...
Auf ein neues System, dass es echte unabhängige Teams gibt, die jeweils einen eigenen Track parkern.
Track heißt sozusagen, ist eine thematische Unterscheidung. Was war es irgendwie, Hardware oder sowas?
Genau, und Science und Politik und Kultur und...
Making.
Genau.
Also Dinge, physikalische Dinge herstellen.
Die... Okay, körperansteigend. Ich frage mich immer noch, ob es schon in der Vorbereitung bei so einem System Grenzen geben kann. Also weil die... Ich stelle mir vor, der Vorteil, wenn man nicht fest beschäftige Leute hat, dass die das machen, ist, dass es natürlich viel billiger wird, was das Geldvolumen angeht. Aber der Nachteil ist, dann ist ja erstmal jeder gleichberechtigt. Habt ihr dann irgendwie so Strukturen, wie regelt ihr das? Also weil ihr gerade von Fresse einschlagen sprach.
Wir alle haben dasselbe Ziel, schon, mit der Veranstaltung. Und da soll was Geiles draus werden. Und da findet man sich am Ende dann zusammen. Da findet man Kompromisse. Und eigentlich ist es auch so ein bisschen Legitimation durch tun. Man macht das erst mal. Und wenn viele Leute sich beschweren, dann macht man es das nächste Jahr nicht mehr.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz gibt es trotzdem immer wieder Guttreibereien. Im Club ist es nun mal so, dass wir viele sehr starke Persönlichkeiten haben. Und wenn wir zwei aufeinandertreffen, die gegenteilige Meinungen haben, dann ist nichts mit, wir finden einen Mittelweg. Sondern dann wird erst mal aufeinander gekloppt. Und irgendwann kommt dann doch was ganz Gutes bei raus.
Jetzt stell dich mir vor, beim Hausaussuchen hat es wahrscheinlich keinen größeren Verpeiler gegeben. Weil das wäre wahrscheinlich relativ schnell aufgefallen. Aber gibt es jetzt in diesem Stadium, also wir sind jetzt, wenn man sich so eine Großveranstaltung anguckt, sind wir immer noch in der Vorplanung. Also da hat noch keiner ein Ticket oder so was. Sondern die Leute sind tatsächlich, also es gibt die Idee, das zu machen, es gibt einen Veranstaltungsort, es gibt auch einen Plan, wer das den Raum kümmert und es gibt ein Vorlesungsprogramm. Sind da schon mal Dinge passiert, wo man im Nachhinein sagt, oh mein Gott, da ist ja eigentlich alles explodiert?
Also, naja, so CFP, also der Call for Paper, ist halt selten zu dem Zeitpunkt rausgekommen, wie wir versucht haben, dass er rauskommt. Also wir haben halt immer so Ende Mai angeplant, aber es wurde dann halt tatsächlich manchmal auch wirklich Juni, Juli, August, also wirklich später. Aber halt so, also dadurch, dass wir halt noch so weit vorne sind, hat sich das alles wieder irgendwie eingesperrt. Also es gab sicherlich irgendwie Probleme und Pannen, aber halt nichts, was sich halt irgendwie jetzt wirklich negativ ausgewirkt hätte.
Okay, das heißt, wir sind wir dann eigentlich schon bald daran, dass der Kongress losgehen kann im Sinne von, dass die konkrete Planung tatsächlich anfängt. Wie, da noch ganz kurze Frage, der Kongress geht ja immer los am 27. Danke, das verantwortet meine Frage. Wann geht, also sagen, wann, wie soll man sagen, wann betritt zum ersten Mal ein Mensch, der konkret mit dem Kongress zu tun hat, den Veranstaltungsort?
Na also natürlich vorher, also wirklich im August, September, Oktober, je nachdem, wir haben ja dieses Jahr zum Beispiel auch wieder neue Räume dazu gekriegt. Das heißt, dann gab es halt irgendwie auch Gruppen, zum Beispiel, die diese neuen Räume bespielt haben, die sich die auch nochmal separat angucken wollen. Dann gibt es natürlich halt so die Orga, die halt hinfährt und sich mit dem Haus unterhält. So richtig los, was den Kongress betrifft, ging es dieses Jahr am 19. Dezember. Also die ersten paar Tage ist halt hauptsächlich, also wir haben halt eine große Halle, da wo dann auch die Lounge drin ist, also die Bar. Und das ist praktisch so Anlieferungsort. Also da kommen halt Getränke, dann kommen halt die ganzen, der ganzen Strom, die ganze Deko, die ganze Hardware. Irgendwie alles, was halt so über den Kongress in das Kongressgebäude reingetragen wird, kommt halt erst mal an und wird halt erst mal ausgepackt und sortiert.
Und natürlich ist schon mal Party. Naja, also sonst würde man sich das auch nicht ans Bein binden, wenn man nicht noch ein bisschen Spaß hätte.
Das hört man dem Erdgeist noch heute an. So, also wir stehen mitten in den Vorbereitungszeiten für den Kongress. Es geht dann gleich richtig los, aber vorher machen wir das Nachrichten, die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht's weiter hier im Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Fritz.
Habt ihr manchmal Lust, einfach einen Rucksack zu packen und euch einen Flieger zu schnappen? Einfach irgendwo hin auf der Welt, wo es schön und warm ist und wo ihr noch niemals wart und da dann einfach mal losziehen und gucken, was passiert? Genau das könnt ihr haben. Weltweit back, schon ziemlich bald, mit Fritz.
Mit Martin Schneider.
Um die grenzüberschreitende Kriminalität besser zu bekämpfen, hat der Bundestag heute dem deutsch-polnischen Polizeiabkommen zugestimmt. Dadurch können Polizisten im jeweiligen Nachbarland Verdächtige überprüfen und festnehmen. Außerdem sollen deutsch-polnische Teams auf Streife gehen. Und Polizeihubschrauber müssen bei der Verfolgung von Flüchtenden nicht mehr an der Grenze umkehren. Die Europäische Union verlängert die Sanktionen gegen ukrainische und russische Staatsbürger bis September. Darauf haben sich die EU-Außenminister in Brüssel geeinigt. Konkret geht es um Reise- und Vermögenssperren für mehr als 130 Personen und fast 30 Unternehmen. Dem Betroffenen wird vorgeworfen, die prorussischen Separatisten im Osten der Ukraine zu unterstützen. Keine Einigkeit gab es hingegen in der Frage neuer Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen Russland. Bei diesem Thema werden sich die Staats- und Regierungschefs der EU Mitte Februar beschäftigen. Im Nordirak werden künftig bis zu 100 deutsche Soldaten, kurdische Verbände, für den Kampf gegen die Terromeliz islamischer Staat ausbilden. Mit den Stimmen der Koalitionsfraktionen von Union und SPD stimmte der Bundestag mit großer Mehrheit für die Mission. Bedarfsweise soll die Bundeswehr auch für die Lieferung von Hilfsgütern und militärischen Material in den Nordirak sicherstellen. Die Opposition aus Linkspartei und Grünen äußerte Zweifel an der rechtlichen Zulässigkeit an dem Einsatz, der weder unter dem Dach der Vereinten Nationen noch im Auftrag von EU oder NATO stattfindet. Sport. In der Zwischenrunde des Basketball Eurocups ist Alba Berlin gerade bei Roter Stan Belgrad zu Gast. Auf dem Weg zum Viertelfinale wäre für Alba ein Sieg wichtig. Im Moment liegt Alba mit 65 zu 83 zurück. Das Wetter. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Marzahn haben wir 0 Grad, in Pankow 1 Grad, Ludwigsfeld und Wittenberg 0 Grad, Eberswalde und Forst 1 Grad. Die Tiefstwerte der Nacht haben wir damit eigentlich schon fast überall erreicht. Bis auf minus 1 Grad geht es runter. Dazu gibt es Regen oder auch Schneeschauer. Vorsicht also auf den Straßen, die können ordentlich glatt werden. Morgen geht es dann erstmal mit Regen los. Am Nachmittag soll es dann meist trocken sein und das Ganze bei maximal 4 Grad. Die Straßen sind teilweise glatt, aber größtenteils frei. Da wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Das bedeutet heute sind Leute vom Chaos Computer Club hier. Wie nennen sie es selber glaube ich? Intergalaktische Hacker-Vereinigung von Lebendewiesen oder irgendwie so ähnlich?
Du lernst so was auswendig krass.
Ja einer muss ja. Und die heute mal erzählen, wie man eine Großveranstaltung organisiert, weil wie so vieles machen die Nerds natürlich auch die Großveranstaltung selber und erklären heute mal wie das geht. Und zu Gast sind Starbuck, Danimo und Erdgeist. Habt ihr gerade irgendwas genommen während der Nachrichten? Oder warum müsst ihr so kichern?
Im Studiski-Stimme.
Unglaublich. Ihr seid auch aufgerufen anzurufen, wenn ihr mögt. Der Chaos Communication Congress ist eine riesige Veranstaltung. Zehntausend Leute waren noch nicht mal da. Falls ihr einer davon wart, könnt ihr gerne anrufen, eine Geschichte davon erzählen. Wie hat es euch gefallen oder falls ihr von den Machern wissen wollt, was das ist und eine ganz bestimmte Frage habt, könnt ihr auch gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Wir haben in der ersten halben Stunde schon kurz geklärt, wie die Anfänge sind, also dass man ein Haus suchen muss und dass dann die Leute, die dort Vorträge halten, auch irgendwie organisiert werden müssen. Ihr habt auch erklärt, dass das alles Freiwillige machen, die dafür kein Geld kriegen und sogar noch Eintritt bezahlen. Und wir sind jetzt sozusagen kurz davor, bevor der Kongress losgeht. Ich würde dann gerne mal wissen wollen, was ich gemerkt habe ist, dass viele Hacker und Nerds dazu zindieren, alles selber zu machen. Jetzt stelle ich mir vor, so ein Anmeldungssystem, so eine Software, die Mitglieder und Nichtmitglieder und Ticketpreise und was auch immer veraltet. Und dann noch sozusagen dieses System, dass man vor Ort sein Ticket herzeigt, das wird eingescannt oder man muss es noch bezahlen. Habt ihr das auch selber programmiert?
Also das hat ganz praktische Gründe, weil wir natürlich sehr auf Datenspassamkeit aus sind und versuchen, so wenig wie möglich Daten von unseren Mitgliedern oder Besuchern an fremde Firmen rauszugeben. Und da war es einfach selbstverständlich, dass es zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt selbstgeschrieben wurde. Irgendwann ging es los, als wir einen Vorverkauf hatten. Ich hatte nicht immer Vorverkauf. Früher war es so, du bist einfach hingegangen, hast das Geld auf den Tisch gelegt, hast deinen Ticket bis reingegangen. Ab einer gewissen Größe des Hauses musste man Vorverkauf machen. Da ist zwangsweise so ein Ticketsystem dabei.
Das war schon praktisch, das Geld im Vorfeld in der Hand zu haben, das Haus zu bezahlen, um Shirts drucken zu lassen und was um Anfälle.
Was kostet eigentlich so ein Haus, wo ihr es gerade sagt?
Man kann sehr grob durchrechnen, wie viele Leute da waren, was der Eintritt gekostet hat.
Der große Teil geht dafür für das Haus drauf.
Im BCC haben wir einen wirklich guten Preis gekriegt. Die sind für uns richtig runtergegangen für den normalen Preis. Auf der anderen Seite bist du in der Zeit zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr, wo normalerweise nicht so richtig viele Veranstaltungen sind. Wenn erst mal Weihnachten vorbei ist, dann ist bis Anfang Januar die Häuser meistens leer.
Die müssen ihre Mitarbeit auch bestechen, da jetzt hinzugehen.
Viele kommen zwischendurch sehr gerne zu uns. Der große Unterschied zu anderen Veranstaltungen von professionellen, BMW-Hauptversammlungen ist, dass wir Dinge selber tun. Das ist im ersten Jahr für das Haus sehr ungewohnt, weil sie denken, sie müssen jetzt alles machen. Sie geben die Schlüssel nicht raus, weil das kennen sie nicht so. Sie merken aber, dass trotz des Chaos-Im-Namen das in der Regel gut funktioniert. Wir kriegen seit Jahren wirklich immer Lobe von allen Gruppen, die das Haus bespielen. Sei es von der IT, die sich zurücklehnen kann und nix mehr machen muss, weil wir alles selber stecken. Bis zum Vermietern selber oder den, wie auch immer sie heißen, bei den Häusern, die sich freuen, dass wir das Haus fast sauberer übergeben, als wir es vorgefunden haben. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es auch immer wieder ein paar Sachen, die kaputt gehen, was bei einer BMW-Hauptversammlung wahrscheinlich eher nicht passiert. Aber das ist dem geschuldet, dass wir auch mit großen Hubwagen durch die Hallen fahren, weil wir dann das Haus komplett umgestalten. Wer nicht beim Kongress war, kann sich das schwerlich vorstellen. Das ist ein normales Kongresszentrum und du erkennst es in den Jahren, also zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr, erkennst du es einfach nicht wieder. Das ist einfach so umgestaltet, so bunt. Wir machen sehr viel Deko. Guck dir einfach mal ein paar Videos, gibt es ja im Netz, wie dir das irgendwie aussah.
Ich empfehle eine Suche nach z.B. 31C3 auf Licker oder so etwas. Da kriegt man einen sehr schnellen Eindruck, wie bunt und wie angenehm das eigentlich ist. Man kennt ja eigentlich Konferenzzentren wirklich nur so als Neonröhren beleuchtete hässliche Klötze.
Und dann Werbung, Werbung, Werbung, Werbung, Sponsor 1, Sponsor 2, genau.
Und hier ist es wirklich so, das Licht ist teilweise angenehm runtergedämmt, es sind schön rauhnte Farben.
Ich verstehe das schon. Nein, wir wollten darüber reden, wie man so ein Ding organisiert, damit es möglicherweise da draus noch jemand nachmachen kann. Vielleicht nicht gleich in dieser großen Ordnung, aber...
Also da können wir, wo wir gerade hier Hostessen und Werbung angesprochen haben, das ist halt noch so ein außergewöhnlicher Fakt, dass halt der Kongress, also wir haben halt durchaus Sponsoren, aber wir sagen den Sponsoren auch im Vorhinein, wir fänden es schön, wenn ihr uns sponsert, aber ihr werdet irgendwie keine Hostessen hinstellen und irgendwie keine Flyer verteilen. Also ihr kriegt halt, also wir haben eine Sponsoring-Seite, wo sie halt irgendwie ihr Logo draufkriegen und denen wird halt auch gedankt, aber das war es dann in der Regel auch. Wir hatten vor ein paar Jahren, in Berlin war es noch der Fall, ich glaube, Vodafone, wer waren das? Also die haben das halt irgendwie nicht verstanden, was wir ihnen gesagt haben, oder die Kommunikation ging schief und dann standen halt auf einmal so zwei leicht bekleidete, junge Damen, die halt Kugelschreiber verteilt haben und es ist halt so, der war es nach hinten losgegangen, also weil die Nerds konnten damit nichts anfangen, für die war es auch total absurd, weil wie gesagt, es gibt normalerweise kein Sponsoring oder keine offene Werbung und auf einmal stehen da halt irgendwie so Leute, die halt Kugelschreiber verteilen und wir haben es dann halt wirklich ganz schnell, als wir es mitgekriegt haben, mit denen gesprochen und gesagt, das war nicht abgesprochen, das geht so nicht, die müssen hier weg und dann hat sich das auch relativ schnell geklärt.
Okay, so wir waren gerade abgeschwiffen vom selbstgeschriebenen Kassensystem, da gab es auch keine größeren Expositionen. Ich hoffe immer noch auf so ein paar.
Da ist ziemlich viel selbstgeschrieben. Das Konferenzplanungssystem für den Inhalt zum Beispiel ist schon in einer zweiten Iteration. Das hieß ursprünglich PentaBARF, war glaube ich ein PAP geschrieben und wurde dann irgendwann abgelöst durch den FRAP. Und dort können von der Einreichung bis zur Planung des genauen Fahrplans kann alles auf unserem eigenen Server auch geplant werden.
Und die Tools, die da geschrieben werden für die Konferenz, die greifen auch wunderbar ineinander, einfach weil die Daten in diesem Konferenzplanungssystem zum Beispiel vorliegen und wir irgendwie, da werden wir auch gleich nochmal darüber sprechen, natürlich auch die Vorträge aufzeichnen. Um diese Aufzeichnung dann sehr schnell online stellen zu können, braucht man natürlich fast genau die Metadaten aus dem Konferenzsystem. Das heißt die Tools, die dann für die Aufzeichnung gebraucht werden.
Okay, okay, ich habe verstanden. Das ist alles total super. Frage, ist das ganze Zeug open source und jeder andere kann das auch benutzen?
Natürlich. Absolut.
Sehr gut. Wunderbar. So, jetzt wollen wir ein bisschen anfangen über die einzelnen, wie nennt man das, Gewerke zu sprechen. Es gibt ja verschiedene Unterteilungen, die da Dinge tun. Wir hatten am Anfang schon kurz von Engeln gehört. Also Engel sozusagen die Helfer, die...
Die haben sich ihre Software übrigens auch selbst geschrieben.
Natürlich haben sie ihre Software auch selbst geschrieben. Aber was da genau passiert, wird uns jetzt jemand sagen, der mit Dreck zu tun hat beim Cross, nämlich JZ, der jetzt am Telefon ist. Hallo und guten Abend. Ja, du haltest ein bisschen extrem stark. Weil du ja in der Flughafenhalle bist?
Ja, so in der Art.
Na gut. Was genau ist deine Aufgabe gewesen beim Kongress mit den Engeln?
Ich bin unter anderem dafür zuständig, dass die ganze Arbeit, die anfällt, getan wird. Und das mache ich natürlich nicht selber, sondern ich habe ein Team von 15 Leuten, die dafür sorgt, dass die ganzen Engel, wir haben ja vorhin schon gesagt, wir haben knapp 1300 ehrenamtliche Helfer gehabt, die mal an der Tür gestanden haben oder Getränke, Leergut gesammelt haben oder so, dass die wissen, was sie machen sollen und das Schichten oder Arbeit, die zu tun ist, wo sich noch niemand selber eingetragen hat, dass das irgendwie aufgefüllt wird. Und ihr habt ja schon gesagt, wir haben so ein schönes System und die Helfer kriegen von uns nicht gesagt, was sie zu tun haben, sondern können sich das selber aufsuchen. Also alles, was zu tun ist, gibt es halt in diesem System und da können die sich selber reinklicken und sagen, ich mach das jetzt und dann machen die das auch.
Und bleiben da manchmal Arbeiten liegen, also könnt ihr mir vorstellen, es ist sehr beliebt, den Einlass zu dem Saal zu machen, wo der Vortrag läuft, wo sowieso alle hinwollen und es ist sehr unbeliebt, durchs Gebäude zu laufen und leere Flaschen einzusammeln.
Nee, das ist in der Tat nicht so. Also dadurch, dass wir so viele Leute haben, gibt es auch unterschiedliche Interessen, sag ich mal. Und es finden sich immer Leute, die mit Herzblut dabei sind, die ganzen leeren Flaschen zu sammeln. Und da auch richtig Spaß dran haben. Kann ich nicht so nachvollziehen, aber die haben richtig Spaß dabei. Das ist auch richtig cool.
Ein gutes Beispiel ist, glaube ich, der, der die Garderobe immer macht, also seit Jahren, wie heißt der? Ist ja auch egal. Der Garderobe, Engel? Also seit, glaube ich, fast seit ich auf dem Kongress bin, sitzt er halt jedes Jahr an der gleichen Stelle, macht die Garderobe wirklich von dem ersten Tag bis zum letzten Tag und kriegt, glaube ich, überhaupt gar nichts vom Kongress mit, weil er halt wirklich die ganze Zeit an der Garderobe sitzt, aber macht das auch wirklich leidenschaftlich und macht das auch super. Und genau, also genau das ist halt ein gutes Beispiel, wie halt dieser Kongress läuft. Also es gibt einfach Leute, die dediziert sich wirklich mit ihr Herzblut reinstecken, nachts an der Tür Wache zu halten, weil sie das halt gern tun. Und zu Engel muss man dazu sagen. Also ich glaube, jeder oder fast jeder, der halt irgendwie schon seit einer Weile im Club ist, hat irgendwie mal als Engel am Kongress angefangen. Also als ich in Hamburg vor 13. war mein erster, saß ich halt auch die ersten zwei Jahre irgendwie nachts irgendwie am Eingang, hab irgendwie mit zwei anderen Leuten Filme geguckt. Das war halt einfach, also so kommt man halt einfach irgendwie rein.
Das ist ein eigenes Oziotop, ja.
Auf jeden Fall. Also es gibt halt auch, also Engel sind ja immer so in Schichten, also die machen halt immer so zwei Stundenschichten oder wie viel auch immer und da gibt es halt dann auch so richtig Wettbewerb gegeneinander. Also die sagen, oh ich bin schon seit drei Tagen wach, hab nicht geschlafen, hab schon mehr Schichten als du.
Also.
Aber sag mal, JZ, ist das dann so, dass man, dass du quasi, dass deine, dass die komplizierte Aufgabe ist dann darauf zu achten, dass die Leute nicht zu wenig machen, sondern, dass sie nicht zu viel arbeiten und nicht umfallen? Also ich mein, weil, so wie ihr es bis jetzt erzählt, hört sich das schon alles sehr, sehr paradiesisch an und ich kann mir trotzdem vorstellen, so eine Veranstalterung von 10.000 Leuten und wo 1000 Helfer dabei sind, hat auch Herausforderungen. Ich versuche gerade herauszufinden, wo die sind.
Du fragst die falsche Person, JZ gehört nämlich zu denjenigen, die die ganze Zeit nicht schläft und immer nacht ist.
Also ich denke, die größte Herausforderung ist tatsächlich nicht, dass die ganze Arbeit gemacht wird, weil das passiert fast schon alleine, sondern die größte Herausforderung ist, auf die ungeplanten Dinge zu reagieren und Informationen zu verteilen. Also bei uns in diesem Himmel, das ist der Ort, wo diese Engel sich ganz gerne aufhalten, wenn sie gerade nicht arbeiten und wo alles koordiniert wird, da melden sich die Engel halt auch, wenn sie Probleme haben. Und dann kann das halt auch mal passieren, dass nachts um drei irgendwie das Funkgerät angeht und irgendjemand sagt, hallo Himmel, was ist denn eigentlich mit dem Feuer im Saal ein?
Ist da was wirklich schon mal passiert?
Ja, ja, das ist letztes Jahr passiert.
Oh mein Gott, was war mit dem Feuer im Saal eins?
Na ja, da war halt kein Feuer im Saal eins, sondern da war ein bisschen Blut in der Feuerschale vor dem Foyer vom Saal eins.
Draußen? Also du kannst dir vorstellen, was irgendwie in den zehn Minuten los war, bis die Leute realisiert haben, was wirklich los ist.
Ich habe nur noch einmal nachgesagt, hast du gerade wirklich Feuer und Saal eins in einen Satz gesagt und bin losgerannt. War dann alles überhaupt gar nicht so stressig und es war alles total super, aber die Nacht ging noch weiter und es gibt auf dem Kongress gerade in den Nachtschichten immer ganz, ganz besonders tolle Dinge. Ich kann mich noch an einen Menschen erinnern, der in Berlin durchs Gebäude lief, in Boxershops und meinte, ihm werde seine Hose geklaut worden.
Okay, hat sich das auch irgendwie anders aufgekehrt oder?
Ja, ja, also nachdem wir erst mal eine halbe Stunde lang mit Taschenlampen überall rumgelaufen sind und diese Hose zu suchen, habe ich irgendwann rausgestellt, dass dieser Typ wohl unter dem Einfluss von irgendwelchen bewusstseinserweiternden Substanzen im Bällebad gesessen hat, sich seine Hose ausgezogen hat, zwei Meter weitergegangen ist, sich schlafen gelegt hat und halt nicht mehr wusste, was passiert ist.
Das Bällebad ist übrigens eine der wichtigen Teile vom Kongress. Also es gibt quasi kein Kongress ohne Bällebad. Das ist einfach ein riesiges Schwimmpool quasi, der voller kleiner Plastabelle ist.
Wie bei McDonalds.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, schwedische Möbelhäuser, aber...
Ist halt wichtig, Kongress ist immer superlativ und natürlich sind wir auch der größte Spielplatz.
Letzte Frage noch an JZ. Wenn jetzt jemand sich fragt, Engel, könnte ich euch auch mal machen. Würdest du das empfehlen für Leute, die noch gar nicht auf dem Kongress waren? Oder ihr sagen, erst mal so angucken und dann kann man vielleicht noch mal Engel machen?
Ich würde sagen, wenn man das erste Mal auf den Kongress kommt, sollte man als allererstes in den Himmel gehen und fragen, was man denn tun kann. Denn wenn man da so zwei Stunden, falls ich mich in der Eingangstür bewacht oder Flaschen sammelt oder sowas, lernt man ja dabei Leute kennen, weil man macht das mit anderen Menschen zusammen. Und wenn zwei Menschen zusammen irgendwo stehen, dann passiert das ja häufig mal, dass man sich unterhält. Und das sind halt manchmal auch Leute, mit denen man sich nicht mal eben so unterhalten hätte oder vielleicht nicht direkt ins Gespräch gekommen wäre.
Also nichts schweißt du zusammen, wie halt wirklich einen Nachtdurch mit jemanden zusammen, langweilig irgendwie an der Tür zu sitzen. Also ich kenne also den, mit denen ich damals irgendwie auf dem ersten Kongress war, den treffe ich halt heute noch. Also es ist einfach Freundschaften.
Verstehe. JZ, dann erst mal vielen Dank und ich bitte dich, bitte schlafe bis zum nächsten Kongress noch ein bisschen. So, das sind also die Engel und ich hatte ja angeboten, dass ihr anrufen könnt, wenn ihr Fragen an die Veranstalter haben und jetzt, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass ich sowas noch mal erleben darf, aber jetzt ruft Ole an. Ole ist 20, kommt aus Hamburg, hallo und guten Abend, Ole. Du sagst doch mal kurz eine Frage.
Also, kurz so weg, ich hatte letztes Jahr in meinem ersten Kongress bin nachhaltig geflasht worden, da, als ich irgendwann im Hexagon hängen geblieben bin und da neben den Zappwufern an meinem Laptop irgendwie Code geschrieben hab und noch die Mate nebendran und das irgendwie das Normalste von der Welt war, was ich vorher echt nicht kannte. Endlich mal normale Leute wirklich. Und hätte jetzt gern gewusst, wenn ich jetzt als Tech-Musiker mit einem Live-Set im Hexagon oder an anderen Ecken auf einen Kongress auftreten möchte, an wen ich mich da wenden kann.
Na, da gibt's genauso eine Kultur-Orga, wie alles andere auch organisiert wird und ich weiß nicht, wie offiziell es ist. Die gehen meistens so rum und schauen, wer da so grob in den Kongress passt. Zum Camp würde es das nächste Mal stattfinden. Ist ein bisschen schwierig. Das ist, glaube ich, nicht so richtig demokratisch offiziell Teil der Veranstaltungsplanung.
Kann er vielleicht irgendwo eine Mail hinschreiben?
Also schreib am besten irgendwie an die Orga-Mail-Adresse. Das ist in der Regel, also letztes Jahr war es 31c3-orgat.cccv.de. Und wir leiten das dann an die passenden Personen weiter. Also ich wüsste auch nicht, wie man es normalerweise macht. Also wie gesagt, eigentlich gerade bei der DJ-Auswahl ist das halt ein sehr geschlossenes System, wo sich die Leute, die Leute kennen und dann sich selber einladen. Also ich glaube, so richtig, also anders als bei Speakern oder Assemblies-Teilnehmern, ist es halt gerade bei den DJs so, das ist, glaube ich, nicht...
Da haben wir noch den kleinen Teil geschlossener Gesellschaft entdeckt, den der Kongress auch zu bieten hat.
Nee, nicht wirklich geschlossen. Das sind meistens schon aus dem näheren Freundeskreis so Fusion-Umfeld zum Beispiel. Sonst Leute, die da auch einfach dasselbe, was wir da tun, freiwillig machen. Und dann natürlich auch die DJs kennen, die auf der Fusion auflegen. Und du musst auch natürlich zum Musiker erst mal überzeugen, auf so eine Veranstaltung zu kommen und...
Hier ist einer, der würde... Na gut, Ole, dann schreib mal ne Mail, vielleicht sind wir dich ja nächstes Jahr auf dem Kongress.
Schönen Abend noch.
Schönen Abend noch, tschüss. So, falls ihr eine Frage habt, vielleicht wollt ihr irgendwo anders den Engel werden, haben wir euch schon gelernt, wie es geht, könnt ihr auch gerne anrufen unter 0331 77 97 110. So, jetzt gibt es auf dem Kongress, wenn man da ist, drei, also es gibt viele schöne Fremdwörter und es gibt viele komische Abkürzungen, es gibt insbesondere POC, NOC und VOC. Was das ist, klären wir jetzt sozusagen in Reihenfolge, also wir fangen vorne an, nämlich beim POC und wir begrüßen dazu recht herzlich den Sascha. Hallo Sascha.
Hallo, schönen guten Abend.
Was ist denn ein POC?
Das ist das Phone Operation Center. Wir kümmern uns darum, dass auf dem ganzen Kongress ein eigenes Telefonnetz aufgebaut wird, was dann sowohl die Orger als auch die Teilnehmer benutzen können.
Was heißt eigenes Telefonnetz? Also da wird ja jetzt irgendwie keine Gerätesteckdosen da sein, wo ich dann mein altes Festnetz-Telefon einstecke oder so.
Doch, wenn du so ein altes Telefon mitbringst, dann können wir das sogar anschließen. Wir hatten das dieses Jahr auf dem Kongress auch. Es gab so drei, vier Leute, die irgendwie auch noch alte Modems mit hatten und da irgendwie ihren C64 dran betreiben wollten. Aber hauptsächlich machen wir das halt, dass wir im gesamten Gebäude schnurlose Telefonantennen aufhängen. Also was man so von zu Hause kennt, diese schnurlosen Telefone. Ja genau, DECT. Die hängen wir im gesamten Haus auf, eigene Antennen, die über die Hausverkabelung gehen. Also wir benutzen quasi 110 Prozent des Hauses und jedes freie Kabel, was es da irgendwie gibt, wird entweder vom NOC, vom Netzwerk Operations Center oder von uns benutzt für irgendwelche Telefonsachen, sodass wir im gesamten Haus nachher Abdeckung haben und Empfang haben und dann kann jeder Teilnehmer oder jeder Besucher von zu Hause sein schnurlos Telefon mitbringen und bei uns anmelden und eine eigene Rufnummer bekommen.
Warum?
Weil es geht und weil wir es können.
Die Antwort wirst du halt noch öfter hören, wenn du solche Fragen stellst.
Ich werde es trotzdem jedes Mal fragen müssen. Wie viele Leute bringen dann ihre Telefone mit? Also hat jeder von den 10.000 eins da gehabt?
Nee, also auf dem 31C3 hatten wir insgesamt so knapp, also es waren etwas unter 4.000 Leute oder etwas unter 4.000 Geräte, die wir hatten. Das sind halt auch jede Menge von den Engeln. Also die Engel werden mittlerweile auch dazu angehalten, dass sie doch bitte ein schnurlos Telefon mitbringen sollen, damit sie auch erreichbar sind während des Kongresses. Die bekommen dann nicht nur so eine interne eigene Nummer, die vierstellig ist, sondern sind auch von außen mit einer eigenen Rufnummer erreichbar. Wir haben da so einen richtig großen und schönen Rufnummernblock, wo man dann eine eigene Rufnummer von außen bekommt. Es gibt auch jedes Jahr so ein kleines Budget, dass man auch kostenlos nach draußen telefonieren kann. Normalerweise so ins Festnetz. Dieses Jahr hatten wir sogar Handy mit an, weil so wenig genutzt wurde, dass es dann auch egal war. Dann kam da nicht so viel zusammen. Und wie gesagt, sind insgesamt so ungefähr 4000 Telefone gewesen. Davon waren knapp 1500 Decks, dann 1800 GSM, also so Handys. Wir hatten dieses Jahr nicht nur ein eigenes Decksnetz.
Moment, man kann da auch noch sein eigenes GSM-Telefone mitbringen?
Ja, richtig. Wir haben eigene GSM-Karten ausgegeben und ein eigenes GSM-Netz betrieben. Auch wieder, weil es geht und weil wir es können. Und weil es einfach noch die Vielfalt ein bisschen erweitert. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die nicht unbedingt zu Hause so ein Schnullos-Telefon haben, aber GSM-Telefone hat irgendwie mindestens noch einer, also jeder noch eins irgendwo zu Hause in der Schublade liegen, was er einfach noch mitbringen kann.
Und die haben Telefonbücher.
Genau, und man kann damit dann auch halt telefonieren und das Telefonbuch benutzen und viele andere Sachen auch noch.
Jetzt frage ich mich hier zum ersten Mal, okay, das macht man aus Bastel Spaß, weil das irgendwie cool ist und funktioniert, aber das geht nicht ganz ohne Technik, die dann auch irgendwann mal Geld kostet. Also ist das irgendwie so ein Sammelsurium an Dingen, die sich über die Jahre angemeldet haben oder woher kommt? Ich stelle mir schon vor, für den Betrieb einer 4.000 Leute starken Telefonanlage braucht es ein bisschen Hardware.
Ja, das stimmt, da braucht es ein bisschen Hardware. Wir haben damals 2001 damit angefangen, bei einem der ersten Camps, wo ich unterwegs war in Holland. Da waren wir eigentlich nur aus Spaß und hatten eine ganz kleine Telefonanlage mit und haben da mehr oder weniger rumgespielt und geübt. Und 2003 war dann ein großes Camp in Berlin von CCC. Da haben wir gedacht, das machen wir jetzt ein bisschen größer und haben uns dann so nach und nach die Hardware zusammengesucht. Ich habe davor zehn Jahre lang solche Telefonanlagen in großem Stil gebaut bei Firmen. Und ja, da sammelt sich halt so das eine oder andere an. Und mittlerweile gibt es den Kram auch zu ganz manierlichen Preisen auf eBay. Das ist also nicht mehr das Aktuellste, aber immer noch gut genug, um damit echt große Telefonanlagen zu bauen.
Und seid ihr da irgendwie mal in Probleme reingelaufen? Weil ich meine, 4000 ist dann halt doch noch mal irgendwie eine Ansage.
Ja, das war dieses Jahr sehr lustig. Wir hatten irgendwann am zweiten Tag, am zweiten Veranstaltungstag das Problem, dass wir auf einmal nichts mehr neu hinzufügen konnten. Die Telefonanlage hat gesagt, nö, nö, du bist jetzt genug. Und wir mussten doch echt erst mal ein paar Minuten drüber nachdenken, wo jetzt das Problem liegt. Und nach etwas Sucherei kamen uns dann auch die einleuchtende Idee und kamen relativ schnell dahinter dann, was das denn letztendlich war. Wir hatten irgendwann mal, als wir diese Telefonanlage das allererste Mal installiert haben und die Software konfiguriert haben, das muss irgendwann um 2003 oder 2004 gewesen sein, haben wir uns gedacht, okay, wie viele Telefone können wir denn so haben, was stellen wir denn hier als maximale Grenze mal ein?
Niemand wird jemals mehr als 500er 12 Kilobyte RAM brauchen.
Genau. Ja, und wir haben uns auf die Zahl 3000 geeinigt, weil 3000, das ist ja, das kommen wir nie hin, auf keinen Fall. Ja, und dieses Jahr war es dann soweit. Und bei 3000 war dann halt einfach erstmal Schluss.
Wie lange habt ihr gebraucht, um es rauszufinden?
Ja, so eine halbe Stunde. Zehn Minuten schweißnass und dann ungefähr, dann halt noch mal so ein paar Minuten hinterher, um dann diese ansprechenden Stellen zu finden, wo man es dann umstellt, inklusive einem Neustart der Telefonanlage, was allerdings keiner gemerkt hat, weil es relativ schnell geht.
Aber ihr habt doch dann irgendwie die Hand voll im Kopf gestangen, also das ist euch aufgefallen ist, oder?
Natürlich, ja, der Klassiker.
Jetzt mal abgesehen von solchen Fällen, stellt euch mal vor, dass das Betreiben der Telefonanlage ja eher so ist. Das ist am Anfang viel Aufriss, aber wenn es steht, läuft es eigentlich von alleine. Wie ist der Kongress für euch selber? Was erlebt ihr da? Oder müsst ihr die ganze Zeit da sitzen und gucken, dass nichts umfällt oder ist es dann entspannt?
Nee, also der Kongress selber, wenn er dann einmal läuft und genügend Leute da sind, die schon angemeldet sind, geht eigentlich. Der ist dann entspannt und zum Spielen. Aber das Problem ist, dass ja an meistens Tag minus eins, also zwei Tage bevor die eigentliche Veranstaltung losgeht, sehr, sehr viele Leute kommen und ihre Decktelefone angemeldet haben wollen, die wir alle einzeln anmelden müssen. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt dieses Jahr das erste Mal mit Engeln angemeldet. Das heißt, wir hatten Engel da sitzen, die Engelschichten normal belegt haben und Decktelefone angemeldet haben bei uns in der Anlage. Ansonsten haben wir das mit den vier, fünf Leuten, die die Anlage auch aufbauen, selber gemacht. Aber wir haben festgestellt, dass wir dann an Tag eins oder Tag zwei sowas von durch sind, wenn man irgendwie 1500 Schnullos Telefon in der Hand gehabt hat und dann auch noch irgendwie bei der Hälfte den Leuten erklären muss, wie sie das dann zu Hause wieder ans Laufen bekommen. Richtig, ja, das war dieses Jahr auch ein ganz großes Thema mit Hygiene und mit Keimen und Erkältungen. Also wir haben uns, glaube ich, noch nie so auf die Hände gewaschen wie auf diesem Kongress, also nach jedem dritten Telefon einmal irgendwie entweder das Desinfektionsmittel gegriffen oder aufs Klo gegangen und die Hände gewaschen.
Komm, wir spielen da noch dazu.
Gott sei Dank alle gesund geblieben im Pock.
Sehr, sehr schön. Gut, dann wissen wir also, wie das funktioniert, dass man ein eigenes Telefonnetz auch aufbauen kann aus so einer Hacker-Großveranstaltung. Sattar hat uns erklärt, wie das geht. Vielen Dank. So, dann machen wir jetzt eine kurze Musik und dann kommen wir zu den Nerd-News und dann geht es weiter hier mit der Wie macht man eine Großveranstaltung im Chaosradio im Blue Moon? Wild West Musik hier im Blue Moon von Red Label Catharis, Ramblin Man heißt der Track, ist Netzmusik, könnt ihr euch runterladen, gibt's unter Creative Commons hier im Chaosradio im Blue Moon, wo es natürlich heute auch Nerd News geben wird, und zwar präsentiert von Martin Schneider. Bitteschön.
Die Webseite Archive Org hat über 2000 Spieleklassiker für die antike Plattform DOS freigegeben. Sie lassen sich direkt im Browser spielen, einige können sogar heruntergeladen werden. Unter den Spielen befinden sich Evergreens, wie Wolfenstein Deidre, Lemmings und Prince of Persia. Archive Org ist bekannt durch das seit 1996 gepflegte Archiv von digitalen Kulturgütern, darunter einer regelmäßigen Kopie des gesamten World Wide Web. Wer ab morgen weiter Facebook nutzt, muss sich künftig mehr Werbung gefallen lassen. Das soziale Netzwerk führt gegen den Widerstand von Politik und Datenschützern seine neuen AGB ein. Damit ist es Facebook erlaubt, auch alle Aktivitäten im restlichen Internet auszuwerten und passende Werbung zu platzieren. Ein Widerspruch gegen die neuen AGB ist nicht möglich. Die einzige Alternative besteht im Löschen des eigenen Profils. Mit einem sogenannten Super Cookie verfolgt der US-Internet-Anbieter Verizon seinen Nutzer im Netz. Dazu injiziert er eigene personalisierte Marker in den Datenverkehr seiner Kunden, mit denen diese von Werbeanbietern wiedererkannt werden können. Zu den Nutzern dieses Tracking-Verfahrens zählen unter anderem Google, Facebook, Twitter und Yahoo. Wehren können sich die Nutzer nur dann, wenn die besuchten Webseiten verschlüsselt per HTTPS erreichbar sind.
Die Nerd-News des Chaos Computer Clubs im Chaosradio in Blumenau, Fritz, präsentiert von Martin Schneider. Herzlich willkommen zurück im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Heute zusammen mit Starbucks, Danimo und Erdgeist. Alles sehr seriöse Leute vom Chaos Computer Club, die wie immer im...
Tänzt du mich grad seriös?
Das ist geheim. Was wollte ich sagen? Ich wollte sagen, dass wir jeden letzten Donnerstag in ungeraden Monaten ja hier das Chaos Radio machen. Das heißt eben vom Chaos Computer Club kommen Leute vorbei und erklären irgendwas, was mit Computerkram zu tun hat im weitesten Sinne. Und heute wollen sie mal einen Blick geben in die Großveranstaltungen, die sie selber machen. Und das finde ich wirklich das Bezaubernde quasi daran. Es gab also diesen Chaos Communication Congress. Zehntausend Besucher waren da bei der letzten Ausgabe und der ist halt selbst organisiert. Also von Freiwilligen, die da wirklich richtig viel Zeit reinbuttern. Und trotzdem funktioniert das irgendwie. Wir haben schon gelernt, dass das, wie gesagt, das ist alle Freiwillige sind, die sogar noch selber den Eintritt zahlen. Wie man so ein Gebäude organisiert, was man mit den Vorträgen macht, wo man die herbekommt und was Engel sind, nämlich die kleine Helferlein und wie man die so managt und was ein POC ist, nämlich ein eigenes Telefonsystem auf dem Chaos Communication Congress und wollen gleich noch lernen, was ein NOC und ein VOC ist. Vorher nochmal den Anruf aufzurufen, ne umgedreht den Aufruf anzurufen, falls ihr selber Fragen zum Chaos Communication Congress habt oder euch nicht traut zu fragen, dann ruft trotzdem an 0371 77 97 21 20. Oder wenn ihr selber schon mal da wart und eine Geschichte zu erzählen habt, könnt ihr auch gerne hier anrufen. 0331 77 97 110. So, nachdem wir vorhin schon gelernt haben, was ein POC ist, er hat es gar nicht erklärt, aber ich glaube, es heißt Phone Operations Center wahrscheinlich, lernen wir jetzt, was ein NOC ist, und zwar von Leon. Hallo und guten Abend. Was ist denn ein NOC?
Ein NOC ist ein Network Operations Center und das macht nichts anderes als Internet.
Warte, Moment mal.
Nur Internet.
Aber Internet gibt es doch mittlerweile überall. Warum braucht man besonderes Internet auf einer Großveranstaltung mit 10.000 Leuten?
Ja, wir wollen das halt selber machen, wie wir alles selber machen wollen, weil das Internet in den Größenordnungen, die wir jetzt haben wollen, gibt es halt nicht einfach so eine Versteckdose.
Was heißt denn Größenordnung?
Na, wir bauen da so Internet mit, ich glaube, einer Bandweite von 50 Gigabit pro Sekunde, hatten wir dieses Jahr. Das ist einfach mal viel größer als alles, was man so kaufen kann am Markt.
Marcus, was sagst du so?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also 50 Gigabit, das sind ja 50.000 Megabit pro Sekunde. Und ich habe zu Hause 50 Megabit pro Sekunde, was die Hälfte von dem ist, was man am Markt so kriegt. Also 100 MBit ist gerade so ein Anschluss, den man gerade handelsüblich noch für zu Hause kaufen kann.
Ja, symmetrisch.
Genau, und du kannst genauso schnell hoch wie runterladen, was ja bei handelsüblichen Anschluss ist.
Ihr wolltet Leon nicht damit selber angeben lassen, oder? So dann Leon, die erste Frage, wo kriegt man denn so viel Internet am Stück überhaupt her?
Na ja, das kommt halt auch aus der Wand. Aber hinter der Dose in der Wand steckt da halt eine Glasfaser, die wir da hinlegen lassen haben. Also im Prinzip ein Kabel in einem Rechenzentrum. Und da haben wir dann ein eigener Hart verstehen. Und dann haben wir dort Verbindungen zu größeren Internet-Providern, die freundlich sind und uns da verschiedene Internet-Anschlüsse zur Verfügung stellen. Und aus den mehreren Anschlüssen bauen wir uns dann halt unser Internet auf dem Kongress zusammen.
Jetzt ist ja die größte Herausforderung, also habe ich als Besucher von Großveranstaltungen, immer die ein WLAN zu bauen, das funktioniert. Und tatsächlich hat auch der Kongress für mich, ich war glaube ich beim Vorletzten, also dieses Jahr war es extrem gut, aber davor war es immer sozusagen sehr brüchig, sage ich mal. Was ist denn die Schwierigkeit daran, ein großes WLAN zu bauen?
Ja, das wird sehr technisch.
Kannst du das auch einfach erklären?
Versuchen nicht technisch zu machen, genau. Das Problem ist halt, dass man funkt da auf einer gewissen Frequenz und auf der Frequenz kann aber immer nur einer gleichzeitig funken. Und wenn wir jetzt ganz viele Leute auf ganz wenig Raum haben, dann müssen die sich im Prinzip die Zeit, in der sie funken können, teilen. Das heißt, die Geschwindigkeit geht für alle runter, wenn es viele sind. Das heißt, was man dann tun muss, ist verschiedene Frequenzen nehmen, aber davon gibt es nicht so viele. Und das heißt, was man dann tun muss, ist einfach verschiedene Exis-Points zu wenden. Also im Prinzip ganz viele Antennen, die immer nur mit ganz wenig Sendeleistung funken, sodass man an verschiedenen Stellen wieder die gleichen Frequenzen nehmen kann, ohne dass sie sich stören. Also im Prinzip solche Sachen muss man dann versuchen, mit Hardware zu erschlagen, indem man da mehr Geräte verwendet. Und am Ende kommt man dann halt auch an physikalische Limits. Das kommt dann auch darauf an, wie gut die Hardware, die man dann dieses Jahr zur Verfügung hat, damit umgehen kann. Weil manche Hersteller machen dann auch gewisse Tricks, um ein bisschen das Rauschen gering zu halten und andere Sachen.
Wo kommt denn die Hardware her? Also nicht nur die WLAN-Hardware, sondern die allgemeine Hardware.
Genau, es gibt einen kleinen Teil, den wir selber haben. Einen anderen kleinen Teil mieten wir. Aber man kann halt nicht alles mieten. Das ist genau wie mit dem Internet, das kann man sich auch nicht kaufen, wenn man den größten Organis haben will. Und da haben wir einfach in der Vergangenheit immer Glück gehabt, dass sich Firmen gefunden haben, die uns sowas halt zur Verfügung stellen. Gegen relativ wenig Gegenleistungen. Also hat Starbuck vorhin schon gesagt, die kriegen eigentlich nichts weiter als irgendwie dann mal ein Logo als Dankeschön auf so eine Seite im Biggie gestellt. Ja, aber da haben wir immer relativ viel Glück, dass wir da an Firmen rankommen, die uns einfach mal so einen Stapel von Routern liefern oder WLAN-Access Points.
Kannst du mal eine Größenordnung sagen, so vom Preislichen her, was wir da so zu stehen haben?
Also von einem Routerhersteller haben wir Hardware im Wert von ungefähr 3 Millionen versichert.
Und das sind nur die Router gewesen?
Ja, ein Großteil der Kernnetzwerke hatte, ja. Das war schon das teure Zeug. Die WLAN-Hardware ist auch noch relativ teuer, da geht keine Größenordnung im Kopf. Die kamen auch von verschiedenen, ein Teil kam vom Hersteller und dann hatten wir noch einfach einen Nerd, der hat auch noch einen Stapel davon rumliegen. Ja, so sammelt man sich das halt zusammen.
Jetzt kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das eine Problem, um ein komplettes Netzwerk aufzubauen, ist tatsächlich die Technik. Das andere Problem, würde ich vermuten, was bei Computer immer so ist, ist das Ding, was da vorsitzt, nämlich der Mensch. Da kann ich mir zwei Arten von Problemen vorstellen. Das eine ist, man hat einfach technische Probleme, weil man mit irgendwas nicht klarkommt. Wie viel Zeit verbringt ihr mit Support-Anfragen? So, mein WLAN funktioniert nicht, hilf mir bitte.
Damit verbringe ich relativ wenig Zeit, denn dafür haben wir einen Helpdesk, und das wird von den Engeln betrieben. Gut gesourced. Die machen da ganz großartige Arbeit und fangen das alles für uns ab, sonst würden wir nämlich zu gar nichts mehr kommen. Dann hätten wir gar keine Zeit, das Internet zu bauen.
Die andere Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, es ist ja generell so, dass Hacker ein Interesse daran haben, Dinge zu, das schöne Wort, was ich hier gelernt habe, zerforschen, also mal nachzugucken, inwieweit in so eine Infrastruktur technischer Natur, wie man da reinkommt, was man alles aufmachen kann usw. Habt ihr damit ein Problem, oder gibt es da so eine Art Nicht-Angriffspakt, weil es ist ja die Struktur für den Chaos-Congress?
Nein, also das Not besteht ja zum größten Teil aus sehr professionellen Leuten, die sowas taktiklich machen. Die haben eine gewisse Erfahrung und wissen, wie man Netzwerke absichert, dass man nicht die eigene Hardware in Griffen bekommt. Das geht schon.
Und wenn das passiert, dann weißt du, wo ihr sie findet?
Wir hatten dieses Jahr auf einen Fall, da haben wir an einer Stelle vergessen, was abzusichern, da irgendwelche Limits zu setzen. Und es ist uns natürlich prompt auf die Füße gefallen, weil ich glaube, das war noch ein Tag, bevor der Congress anfing. Nee, das war entweder der erste Tag, oder der davor. Da hat tatsächlich jemand einfach einen stupiden Angriff gefahren, der einfach dadurch abgefangen wäre, wenn wir in so einer Konfig ein Limit eingetragen hätten, wie das auch normal gewesen wäre, das haben wir einfach vergessen. Und dann waren die Server kurz offline.
Und wie ist das mit, was ich mir auch vorstellen kann, da gibt ja dieses riesige Netzwerk, und das hat eine Anbindung nach draußen. Und da sind 10.000 Leute auf einem Platz, nicht wenige davon Leute, die Interesse an Computersicherheit und Zerforschen haben. Wer kommuniziert eigentlich sozusagen mit der Außenwelt, wenn da irgendwas kaputt geht und festgestellt wird, Moment mal, da gibt es diesen riesigen Internetknotenpunkt aus Hamburg.
Du meinst, wenn sich Leute beschweren, dass jemand ihr System kaputt gemacht hat, dann haben wir so eine Telefonnummer und da rufen dann die Leute ganz böse manchmal an. Also manche sind weniger böse, manche sind mehr böse. Aber wir können halt meistens auch nichts tun, denn wir wissen nicht, wer die User sind. Wir können nicht sagen, wenn der eine RP draus hat, das war der und der User, weil wir die Information selber nicht speichern. Wir versuchen ja auch auf Datensparsenkrankheit zu achten und speichern nur das, was wir wirklich speichern müssen. Und können da meistens auch nichts tun.
Na gut, aber was ihr schon teilweise macht, ist tatsächlich dann den Netzbereich zu blockieren. Also einfach zu sagen, aus dem Kongressenetz wird halt nicht mehr auf diesen Netzbereich zugegriffen.
Genau, das ist halt alles, was wir tun können. Wenn jemand ein Problem hat, dann können wir dafür sorgen, dass er von uns nie wieder Daten bekommt.
Stimmt das, dass das Leute auch präventiv anfragen im Vorfeld?
Ja, das gibt so ein, zwei Fälle. Die kennen uns halt schon und die bitten dann einfach, dass sie auch dieses Jahr wieder geblockt werden.
Und das macht ihr dann auch?
Das erspart dann halt vielen Seiten Ärger.
Okay, die letzte Frage, die ich zu einem Netzwerk auf dem Kongressenetz noch hätte, ist zu sagen, wie muss man sich da als einzelner, also als User verhalten, kann ich dann einfach sagen, problemlos ins WLAN gehen und denken so, ihr passt schon auf mich auf, dass mir nichts passiert oder muss man da besondere Vorkehrungen treffen?
Ne, du bist da am echten Internet. Mit allen Seinen gefahren, also da ist halt keine Firewall davor. Man sollte halt schon dafür sorgen, dass sein Rechner die aktuelle Software hat, dass da keine steinalte Software mit Sicherheitsproblemen draufläuft. Dann wäre es sinnvoll, also einfach gute Praxen anzuwenden.
Keine unnötigen Dienste laufen lassen, die nach außen offen sind.
Genau, keine unnötigen Dienste laufen lassen. Möglichst nicht seine wichtigsten Daten drauf haben. Also gut, dann so ein Rechner kann ja auch mal geklaut werden, ganz plump. Aber falls doch was passiert, dann ist das halt nicht so schlimm. Und solche Sachen. Ja, man soll sowieso immer das Verschlüsseln. Wir bieten jetzt auch ein verschlüsseltes WLAN in jüngerer Zeit. Aber das offene gibt es immer noch. Weil wir einfach gerne zeigen, ja, so ist, so ein sicheres Internet. Kümmert euch um Verschlüsselung. Und es ist halt immer noch ein Hackeyevent. Da kann halt schon was passieren.
Wie viel Zeit steckt ihr da rein?
Äh, in das Internet.
Genau, also sozusagen in diesem Betrieb des NOX. Inklusive, also sagen das ganze Jahr über. Insgesamt, nicht nur auf dem Kongress, sondern insgesamt an Zeit.
Naja, wir haben im Oktober angefangen, zu überlegen, wer macht es dieses Jahr und wer ist dabei. Und dann wird es halt, im Oktober ist noch nicht so viel los, aber im Dezember ist das schon so ein Halbtagsjob mindestens. Und dann waren wir eine Woche vorher, auf jeden Fall. Eine Woche vor dem Kongress vor Ort und haben da raufgebaut.
Letzte Frage an dich wirklich, wenn man da irgendwie 30.000 Kilometer Netzwerkkabel verlegt, wie viel vergisst man davon, wie viel fehlt nachher?
Gute Frage. Weiß ich gar nicht so genau. Es wird immer ein bisschen schwunter, aber das ist jetzt nicht problematisch, weil ich hab jetzt keine genaue Inventur, wie viel Netzwerkkabel wir noch haben. Das ist auch ein Problem, weil wir jedes Mal überlegen müssen, wie viel wir nachkaufen. Wir nehmen uns immer vor, unter dem Jahr mal eine Inventur zu machen.
Bis jetzt ist noch genug Kabel da. Leon Wallers, der erklärt, was das NOC, also das Network Operations Center, auf einer Hacker-Großveranstaltung macht. Jetzt wissen wir, dass man Telefone betreiben kann, dass man Vorträge machen kann, dass man Netzwerk betreiben kann. Wir wissen jetzt insbesondere, was ein POC und ein NOC ist. Wir lernen jetzt, was ein VOC ist, und zwar von Dani Mode, der hier im Studio ist.
Ein VOC ist ein Video Operations Center. Du möchtest wissen, was das ist, nicht was es heißt. Na klar, wir haben jetzt schon diskutiert, es gibt Vorträge und es gibt ein sehr großes Kongresscenter. Aber es gibt immer mal wieder Umstände. Es gibt ja so Leute, die zwischen den Jahren durchaus irgendwelche Verpflichtungen haben oder so, die halt, jetzt guckt nicht so verständnislos, es gibt es. Und diese Leute möchten halt vielleicht auch gerne diese Vorträge entweder im Stream oder wie man auf Neudeutsch so schön sagt, zeitsoverän sehen können. Also quasi dann, wenn sie Zeit haben. Und das dafür sorgen, also quasi wir vom VOG. Das heißt, wir haben dort in den Sälen Kameras stehen. Wir haben Videoregie. Wir haben Engel, die diese Kameras bedienen, die quasi die Sachen zuliefern. Und wir bedienen halt auch den ganzen Rest der Kette. Das heißt, die Videos müssen irgendwie ins Internet kommen, im Internet verteilt werden. Das Ganze muss mit irgendwie auch mindestens irgendwie, ich glaube, im Peak hatten wir mal so 9000 Zuschauer gleichzeitig.
Das sind weniger als Besucher im Haus.
Und das muss halt alles bespielt werden. Und wir haben da quasi eine Truppe zusammengetrommelt, die all das macht. Also quasi vom Saal, vom Aufnehmen bis hinzu, endet hinter dir bei dir im Browser oder im Videoplayer, wird quasi die gesamte Kette abgefackelt. Weil es geht.
Naja, und weil da laufen vier Vorträge immer gleichzeitig. Das heißt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man das immer gucken kann, was man sich anschauen möchte, ist zumindest nicht für die ganze Veranstaltung gegeben. Und da ist es schon schön, wenn man dann auch später noch nachschauen kann, was man verpasst hat.
Und tatsächlich, die meisten Leute kommen auch wirklich halt inzwischen zum Kongress nicht wegen der Vorträge, sondern um halt Leute zu treffen. Aber man will halt trotzdem schon gern wissen, was so neu ist, der der Kund getan wurde. Das heißt, man sitzt dann halt die ersten zwei, drei Wochen nach dem Kongress und guckt sich halt Kongress wie vor dem Wahn.
Ich nehme das immer vor, es klappt nie. Aber dann würde ich sagen, die einfache Lösung ist, wir stellen eine Kamera dahin und dann stecken wir das dann in den Computer ein und dann streamt das irgendwie ins Internet. Das ist dann die einfache Lösung. Ich vermute mal, ihr habt etwas anderes aufgebaut. Also wie viel Technik steckt da bei euch drin?
Extrem viel. Also wir haben die letzten Kongresse, eigentlich müssen wir mal überhaupt so anfangen. Das Ganze ist erstmal nicht auf dem Mist des CCC selber gewachsen, sondern wir hatten immer Hilfe von der FEMM. Das sind die Forschungsgemeinschaft Elektronische Medien der TU Ilmenau. Und die haben das quasi eine ganz lange Zeit gemacht, bis wir dann irgendwann gesagt haben, wir möchten das auch machen. Da hat die FEMM nicht gesagt, boah, ihr seid blöd, macht das doch selber und geht weg. Sondern die machen das mit uns zusammen. Und dieses Jahr war es sogar noch toller. Da hat uns sogar die Arbeitsgemeinschaft für Studie- und Senderfragen der TU Braunschweig mitgeholfen. Das heißt, wir haben das quasi im Dreierverbund gemacht. Und wie man sich das vorstellen kann, so uninahe Veranstaltungen, die haben natürlich irgendwie auch richtig Hardware da stehen. Und wir hatten eigentlich auch übrigens alles als Open Source zu haben, auch unsere Erweiterungen. Haben wir eigentlich immer versucht, darauf zu achten, dass wir jetzt nicht Spezial-Hardware anschaffen, sondern dass wir das mit allgemein Technik machen können. Haben also dann so Boxen uns herstellen lassen, so Flight Cases, wo dann handelsübliche Computer, eine gute Kamera und so etwas drin ist und einen Haufen Kabel. Und damit konnten wir das abfackeln. Dieses Jahr wollten wir es unbedingt in HD produzieren. Und da haben wir dann leider die nicht mehr rechtzeitig alles an Start bekommen. Da ist uns dann dankenswerterweise von diesen beiden Gemeinschaften und von Einzelpersonen, die absurd viel Hardware teilweise im Keller rumstehen haben, ausgeholfen worden.
Das ist dann der Vorteil, wenn man viele Nerds kennt.
Genau.
Bei euch nochmal die Frage jetzt, also beim Phone Operations Center und Network kann ich mir vorstellen, da will man eh nur hin, wenn man eh schon viel Ahnung oder sich für die Materie interessiert. Jetzt kann ich mir vorstellen, so Kamerakind würde man gerne auch mal so machen, dass man denkt so, hey, ich finde das irgendwie cool, ich würde dir gerne helfen. Ist das sozusagen so eine eingeschworene Gesellschaft? Oder kann man auch sagen, hier Leute, ich würde auch gerne was machen, kann ich damit machen?
Na, das sind im Prinzip wieder so Kamerakind kannst du jederzeit machen. Du gehst in unser Engelsystem und sagst, ich möchte für diesen Talk Kamerakind machen. Und wenn dann noch niemand anderes Kamerakind ist, bist du Kamerakind. Und wenn du gerne irgendwie Regie führen möchtest, dann klickst du auf, ich möchte gerne die Regie Schicht übernehmen, dann bist du Regie. Du kriegst natürlich von uns Einführungen und wir finden das natürlich total toll, wenn du dich so ein bisschen mit dem Thema schon auskennst. Weil das ist immer so ein bisschen das Problem, die Leute, die Regie führen, die halten sich dann alle für Roland Emmerich und die die Kamera führen, die hoffen dann auch irgendwie auf einen Oscar. Während meistens irgendwie das Gebot der Stunde ist, irgendwie stille Bilder einzufangen, sodass man wirklich das nachvollziehen kann. Und mit viel Technik kommt natürlich auch viel Spielerei. Und quasi so ein bisschen diesen Impuls, jetzt unbedingt überall schalten zu wollen. Wenn man den einmal unter Kontrolle hat und irgendwie weiß, was man tut, weil es ist ja auch wahnsinnig viele Knöpfe, wir versuchen immer so viel wie möglich abzutapen, aber da bleiben immer noch genug Knöpfe übrig. Und wenn man das einmal unter Kontrolle hat, dann funktioniert das auch sehr gut. Und wir haben dann also auch mit den etwas erfahrenen sehr gute Erfahrungen gemacht. Was nicht heißt, dass wir niemanden Neues mehr nehmen. Wir versuchen auch kontinuierlich quasi die Schulung, die da im Vorfeld passieren. Wir haben da halt nur einen Tag Zeit. Da versuchen wir halt so ein bisschen Schulung zu leisten. Geht halt nur in beschränkter Maß, aber das versuchen wir halt zu verbessern.
Okay, also man lernt auch sagen, nicht alle Jobs sind glamourös. Manchmal geht es auch einfach um Stillhalten. Und im Gegensatz zu sagen, zum Türjob kann man sich dann glaube ich nicht mal mit dem Nachbarn unterhalten, wenn gerade der Talk läuft.
Doch, wir haben natürlich Intercom mit den Kameraleuten.
Hey, der Job ist zwar nicht langweilig, aber wir haben technisches Spielzeug. Sehr schön, wunderbar. So, dann wissen wir jetzt, was ein POC, NOC und VOC ist. Dann fehlt uns eigentlich nur noch die vierbuchstabliche Abkürzung, nämlich Zert.
Die hat uns übrigens dieses Jahr sehr geholfen.
Das kann sie gleich bestens selber erzählen, in Gestalt von Madoc. Hallo, guten Tag. Was ist denn ein Zert?
Das Zert steht als Abkürzung für Chaos Emergency Response Team und ist so der Rettungsengel.
Jetzt Rettungsengel, wenn mir die Mate umgefallen ist oder tatsächlich im medizinischen Sinne?
Also du wirst es dich wundern. Tatsächlich werden wir auch gerufen für Fälle aus der Klasse. Mate ist umgefallen, also so vom Scheregrad tatsächlich. Es geht tatsächlich darum, dass wir zuschauen, wenn es Leuten schlecht geht oder wenn Leute einfach Hilfe brauchen, medizinische Hilfe, die von weiter her kommen, sich im Bereich Hamburg nicht so auskennen, sich an uns wenden und bei uns entweder direkt Hilfe bekommen oder auf jeden Fall dann direkt weitergeleitet werden können, dass wir ohne selber irgendwo stecken zu bleiben, an Stellen weitergeleitet werden, wo sie Hilfe bekommen können.
Aber seid ihr sozusagen alles irgendwie ausgebildete Ersteil von Sanität oder was? Oder seid einfach nur Leute, die sich die Zeit nehmen, um Menschen, die sich in den Fingern geschnitten haben, an die Hand zu nehmen und zu pusten?
Das ist völlig bunt. Also wir haben alle Qualifikationsstufen da. Wir haben Ärzte da, wir haben aber auch Rettungsassistenten, Rettungssanitäter, aber bis auf Leute, die, ich sag mal, zu damals Führerscheinzeiten den Kurs hier Lebensrettung-Sofortmaßnahmen gemacht haben. Aber auch die setzen wir ein. Von den Qualifikationen ist alles bunt da. Und was es so schön macht, ist, dass es ein unheimlich buntes Bild ist. Wir haben Leute, die Wasserrettung bei der DLRG als Hobby machen. Wir haben Leute, die fürs DRK hauptamtlich fahren. Leute, die hin und wieder auf Sanitätsdiensten dabei sind. Wir haben Leute, die als Krankenschwester im Kongo gearbeitet haben. Höhenretter hatten wir dieses Jahr, ganz großartig. Wir waren wirklich auf alles vorbereitet.
Wie viel seid ihr denn so ungefähr?
Also Hilfeangeboten hatten über 100 Menschen. Wir hatten über 100 Leute, die zu uns gekommen sind, und gesagt haben, ich hätte Lust, für euch zu engeln. Da wir dieses Jahr aber jetzt wirklich mal etwas härtere Maßstäbe angelegt haben, ist das dann super, aber wir brauchen Ausbildungsnachweis. Wir brauchen wirklich jetzt den Nachweis deiner Qualifikation, dass du das, was du sagst, also Rettungssanitär oder Rettungsassistent, gemacht hast, dass du das uns einmal zumindest nachweisen kannst, bevor wir dich auf den Patienten auch in dieser Qualifikation loslassen. Und so sind aber immerhin am Ende noch knapp über 70 Helfer übrig geblieben, die fest bei uns eingebucht waren im System als Helfer.
70?
Ja, das sieht immer, man sieht, wir versuchen immer so ein bisschen unterm Radar zu laufen. Man sieht hin und wieder mal so ein paar Zertengel so durch die Menge schleichen, irgendwo im Hintergrund ein bisschen Überblick bewahren.
Aber schon in so einem Westen auch.
Genau, also erkennbar sind wir schon, der eine mehr, der andere weniger. Also einer war dieses Jahr auf jeden Fall sehr klar erkennbar mit dem lauten Ausruf Bidu, Bidu, Bidu. Ich glaube, hier ist noch viel in der Inne oben geblieben. Aber hinter den Kulissen ist es halt mehr. Zu Spitzenzeiten haben wir 15 Leute gleichzeitig im Einsatz etwa. Zur Nerd-Nachtzeit, also nicht das, was jetzt die meisten Leute als Nachtzeit betrachten. Aber wenn halt wenig los ist, dann reduzieren wir auf sechs. Aber das sind halt auch wirklich so viele Leute, die gleichzeitig immer da sind.
Jetzt, ich traue mich nicht zu fragen, aber was sind denn so Fälle, zu denen ihr gerufen werdet? Also jetzt die schlimmsten?
Der absolute Klassiker ist natürlich, habt da mal eine Kopfschmerz-Tablette. Und ich habe mich geschnitten und das Eis von den Cocktails ist so scharf. Und irgendwas ist mir ins Auge gekommen. Aber wir hatten tatsächlich auch Leute in den Jahren, in denen ich dabei war, denen es auch richtig, richtig dreckig ging. Und darum finde ich das Zert so wertvoll, weil es wirklich jetzt den Leuten, die sonst, wenn sie sich so an den Rettungsdienst oder an den normalen öffentlichen medizinischen Hilfsdienst wenden müssten, die werden einfach weg, also so für Stunden, wenn man sich mal an eine Notaufnahme eines großstädtischen Krankenhauses gewandt hat, da man ja manchmal sechs Stunden die profanen Architektur genossen, bevor man überhaupt mal einen Arztkontakt hatte. Und da können wir halt schauen, was wir so aus eigenem Bild sehr viel schneller machen können. Und es sind etwa 250 Leute, nein es sind auf dem Punkt genau 250 Leute, die jetzt am 31 C3 bei uns behandelt wurden, regelrecht behandelt. Das klingt auch erstmal nicht so viel, aber es waren auch schon einige dabei, die wir durchaus über mehrere Stunden, sechs, acht, zehn Stunden bei uns durchgehend behandelt haben.
Was war denn da los?
Unterschiedlich, es gibt welche, die überschätzen sich einfach. Das ist natürlich jetzt ein Event, auf das man sich ein ganzes Jahr freut, und dann gibt man eine Mate nach der anderen, weil man muss wirklich alles mitbekommen, und dann vergisst man aber noch irgendwie was zu essen, und dann gibt man einfach weg.
Das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte, mit dem Engel, der drei Tage nicht geschlafen hat.
Ja, nicht nur Engel, es sind Congress-Teilnehmer. Gerade Leute, die das erste Mal da so alles erzählt bekommen haben, laufen ja rum, wie Alice im Wunderband auf dem Weg durch den Kaminchenbau. Das verschätzt man sich manchmal halt ein bisschen. Und dann gibt es sehr unterschiedlich dieses Jahr immer so ein bisschen mehr Magen-Darm-Infektionskrankheiten. Ich glaube, vorhin hat es jemand erwähnt, Hände war schon mal total auf den Wogen dieses Jahr. Hat sich durchgesetzt, ist auch mal schön, dass so Klassiker auf dem Kongress sich durchsetzen.
Ja, das Wok hat es dann auf die harte Tour gelernt.
Ja, ich meine, das macht es immer so anders. Bei uns waren halt die Witze, wir haben immer so ein bisschen aus Pock geblinzelt, also so in Anerkennung an Douglas Adams. Ich kenne ja die Rasse, die ausgelöscht wurde, weil die Telefonhörer nicht mehr abgewischt wurden. Aber das ist halt das, was es so schön macht, das ist das Nördige. Also anders als andere medizinische Mahandungseinrichtungen.
Ich muss auch sagen, ich war schwerstens begeistert vom CIRT. Also wie sie mit dieser Situation, die aus unserer Sicht schon ins Kritische gegangen ist, wirklich so souverän umgegangen ist, die Ruhe behalten hat, gesagt hat, bleibt mal ruhig, wir kümmern uns drum, wir sagen euch, sobald es so aussieht, als wenn es problematisch werden würde. Also aus Orga-Sicht war es wirklich wie eine Top-Leistung gewesen.
Es gibt tatsächlich das geflügelte Wort von der Kongressseuche. Das ist halt meistens eine Grippe oder so, was hier rumgeht. Aber dieses Mal war es etwas mit Magendarm. Wir müssen gleich Nachrichten machen. Ich habe noch eine letzte Frage an dich. Bei allen anderen Sachen kann ich mir vorstellen, ich möchte das gerne machen, weil ich möchte mit der Technik rumspielen. Diese Faszination erschließt sich mir beim Medikamententeil oder beim Medizinenteil eher nicht. Warum will man das machen?
Das ist unglaublich schwer zu beantworten, die Frage. Das Neue zu entdecken ist für viele nicht so gegeben, weil die meisten gelernt haben, wie das Reboot eines biologischen Systems funktioniert. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich die Arbeitsweise in dem Bereich, also medizinischer Bereich Arbeitsweise, kennt irgendwo jeder, aber es ist hier völlig anders. Also ich arbeite hier neben Menschen und mit Menschen, die so bunt in ihrer Zusammensetzung sind und so völlig anders, jeder für sich, aber trotzdem ist man da in einer Gemeinsamkeit. Das habe ich tatsächlich noch nie irgendwo so erlebt. Und das ist ein unglaublich krasses Erlebnis. Also wir hatten 15-Jährige, die in wirklich verantwortungsvollen Positionen saßen, aber auch super performt haben. Wir hatten ältere Menschen dort, die ihre Sache gestanden haben. Es hat keiner hingeguckt, wer du bist, woher du kommst, aber die gemeinsame Arbeit hat uns verbunden. Und das ist ein Gefühl, das habe ich selten in dem Ausmaß erlebt. Das war großartig.
Und das wird auch noch anderen Menschen geholfen. Das hört sich wirklich sehr gut an. Ein Überblick über das Third hat uns MEDoc gegeben. So, jetzt wissen wir schon ziemlich viel über den Chaos Communication Congress und wie man so eine Großveranstaltung organisiert und produziert. Wir machen gleich noch weiter. Vor allem die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr. Jetzt aber los.
Na toll, gerade wollten wir euch sagen, dass einer der großartigsten Berliner Livebands in einer der schönsten Berliner Open Air Locations und das auch noch in einer der besten Berliner Jahreszeiten spielt. Und dann war das Konzert schon ausverkauft. Damit uns das beim Zusatzkonzert nicht noch mal passiert, lassen wir das gequatsche und starten gleich mit. Fritz präsentiert The Beat Stakes, das Zusatzkonzert.
Freitag, 3. Juli.
The Beat Stakes, live in der Wohleide. Präsentiert von Fritz.
Fritz Nachrichten.
Mit Martin Schneider.
Die neue griechische Regierung will keine einseitigen Schritte bei der Überwindung der Schuldenkrise. Das sagte EU-Parlamentspräsident Schulz nach einem Treffen mit dem neuen Ministerpräsidenten Tsipras. Demnach wolle die Regierung in Athen Lösungen auf gemeinsamer Grundlage suchen. Begrüßenswert sei, dass die Steuerhinterziehung und die Korruption im Land bekämpft werden solle. Tsipras erklärte nach dem Gespräch, Athen wünsche eine Schuldenkonferenz. Dazu werde seine Regierung Vorschläge machen, die mit den Partnern in der Eurozone besprochen werden sollten. Um die grenzüberschreitende Kriminalität besser zu bekämpfen, hat der Bundestag heute dem deutsch-polnischen Polizeiabkommen zugestimmt. Dadurch können Polizisten im jeweiligen Nachbarland Verdächtige überprüfen und festnehmen. Außerdem sollen deutsch-polnische Teams auf Streife gehen. Um Polizeihubschrauber müssen bei der Verfolgung von Flüchtenden nicht mehr an der Grenze umkehren. In die ehemalige Lausitz-Kaserne in Doberluck-Kirchheim sollen im kommenden Herbst die ersten 400 Flüchtlinge einziehen. Bis dahin seien die Gebäude hergerichtet, sagte Brandenburgs Innenminister Schulter am Abend bei einer Einwohnerversammlung. Dabei verteiligte er die Entscheidung für den Standort, der aufgrund des baulichen Zustandes die besten Voraussetzungen biete. Die ehemalige Kaserne soll eine Art Zweigstelle für die überfüllte Erstaufnahmestelle in Eisenhüttenstadt werden. Insgesamt sollen 800 Flüchtlinge untergebracht werden. Alba Berlin hat in der Basketball EuroLeague die dritte Niederlage kassiert. Bei Rotterstan Belgrad verlor der deutsche Vizemeister mit 69 zu 86. Für den serbischen Vizemeister war es der erste Sieg in der EuroLeague. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Köpenick haben wir 0 Grad, in Spandau 2, Lübbenau 2 Grad, Potsdam und Falkensee 1 Grad und Angermünde 0 Grad. Bis auf Minus 1 Grad geht es heute Nacht runter. Dazu gibt es Regen oder Schneeschauer. Vorsicht auf den Straßen, die können ordentlich glatt werden. Morgen gibt es erst mal Regen, am Vormittag zumindest. Am Nachmittag soll es dann meist trocken sein. Das Ganze bei maximal 4 Grad. Die Straßen sind frei, wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr schon immer mal wissen wolltet, wie ein Stimulator klingt, dann hört ihr das jetzt gerade. Aber auch immer sonntags. In der oberhammerkrass starken Action-Super-Show mit mir. Dem Stimulator. Ach ja, Kathrin Thüring und Jakob Lund sind da auch immer dabei.
Die Sonntagsfritzen.
Immer sonntags ab 14 Uhr auf Fritz.
Heute Chaos Radio im Blue Moon zu Gast sind vom Chaos Computer Club Erdgeist, Danny Mohn und Starbuck. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und wir reden heute darüber, wie der Chaos Computer Club sowas wie den Chaos Communication Congress organisiert. Das machen nämlich alles Freiwillige und wir haben so die verschiedenen Baustellen, die man braucht, um so eine zehntausend Leute Veranstaltung auf die Beine zu stellen. Man fragt sich mal, wie macht man sowas eigentlich? Das wird heute so ein bisschen genauer erklärt. Und wir haben tatsächlich euch auch aufgerufen, anzurufen, falls ihr selber auf dem Kongress wart und dazu etwas erzählen wollt. Und das ist tatsächlich passiert, nämlich der Pluto hat angerufen. Pluto ist 20, kommt aus Wien. Hallo und guten Abend.
LUTO.
Ah, das wurde mir falsch aufgeschrieben. Du warst auf dem Kongress.
Ich war auf dem Kongress und ich bin ein bisschen krankheitsmäßig umgekippt und wollte mich eigentlich mal an Zert bedanken, weil ich während dem Kongress nicht wirklich dazu gekommen bin. Ich bin wirklich extrem nett um mich gekümmert.
Also Zert, das hatten wir gerade vor den Nachrichten erklärt, das sind die Leute, die sich auf dieser großen Veranstaltung um die medizinischen Notfälle kümmern. Da hatten wir Madoc gerade am Telefon und du bist ihm quasi in die Hände gefallen.
Kann man so sagen, ja.
War das dein erster Kongress?
Nein, es war mein zweiter. Ich war am 30.3. zum ersten Mal und ja, es war dementsprechend der zweite.
Wie würdest du jemanden, der noch gar nicht auf dem Kongress war, das beschreiben?
Den Kongress allgemein? Ziemlich, also der erste war ziemlich überwältigend.
Weil, was passiert da?
Ich bin wirklich reingekommen und es ist, man kommt auf den Bahnhof. Also in Hamburg ist halt der Bahnhof dort, der Dammtor, der Bahnhof. Und man kommt wirklich rein in eine komplett andere Welt. Also es ist alles dekoriert, es sind alle extrem freundlich. Man hat überall irgendjemand, den man einfach anreden kann, der mir was braucht. Und es sind viele Menschen, die man einfach fragen kann, was sie da gerade tun und die erklären das dann einfach so.
Das heißt, man muss da keine Angst haben?
Nein, Angst gibt, also ich hätte nicht mitbekommen, dass ich Angst gehabt habe am Congress.
Sehr schön. Gut, dann wolltest du also nur deinen Dank sozusagen beim Zert nochmal abgeben? Dann sei das hiermit geschehen und vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. So, das ist wirklich harzerwärmend, diese Geschichten. Es gibt also da Netzwerke und ein eigenes Telefonnetz und medizinische Notfälle, da wird sich auch drum gekümmert. Und es wird sich auch um die Leute gekümmert, die zum aller, aller, erstmal da sind, sich nicht so richtig trauen. Und zwar von den sogenannten Chaos-Party-Nen. Und was das ist, erklärt uns jetzt Fiona. Hallo und guten Abend. So, Chaos-Party-Nen. Was sind die? Was machen die? Warum gibt es die?
Die Chaos-Party-Nen, das ist ein Programm, das es seit letztem Jahr gibt. Und, was wir schon gesagt, wir betreuen neue Leute, die zum ersten Mal auch in Konkret kommen, in den sie ihre Fragen beantworten und auf den Kongress, in dem wir ihnen Paten zuordnen, die sie willkommen heißen, auf den Kongress rumführen und für sie Ansprechpartner sind. Und witzigerweise, der Lutho, der gerade anrufen hat, war selber Chaos-Pate. Und dem auch nochmal vielen Dank, dass er einen Chaos-Party gemacht hat. Es sei denn, es war ein anderer Lutho, aber das bezweifle ich.
Das war wirklich der Lutho.
Die Chaos-Paten sind ja genau wie alle anderen Leute auch Freiwillige. Wer meldet sich denn da so? Sind das die ganz alten Hasen oder Leute, die auch erst zum dritten Mal da sind? Oder wie funktioniert das?
Von den Paten und Patinnen, also ja, es gibt so die Leute, die einfach schon seit zehn Jahren dabei sind oder länger und gerne etwas weitergeben möchten von ihrer Begeisterung. Aber erfreulicherweise hatten sie dieses Jahr zum Beispiel auch Patenkinder von letztem Jahr dabei, weil die letztes Jahr selber Patenkinder waren, bei den Chaos-Patenern zum ersten Mal und meinten, ja, sie würden gerne ihre tollen Erlebnisse und was sie so gelernt haben, weitergeben an die Leute, die dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal dabei waren, also beim Kongress.
Und wie macht ihr es dann? Teilt ihr einfach sozusagen die Zahl der Chaos-Kinder durch Paten, die zur Verfügung stehen, und dann werden die einfach mitgegeben oder wird das noch irgendwie besonders ausgelost?
Das ist auf jeden Fall Teil des Prozesses, damit man sagen kann, wie groß die Gruppen ungefähr sind. Aber es fängt eigentlich so ein bisschen vor dem Kongress an. Ein paar Wochen vorher machen wir das Publik, dass es uns wieder gibt. Und dann kann man sich bei uns anmelden mit einer E-Mail und ein bisschen was über sich erzählen. Und wir verwalten das Ganze in so einer Software. Und dann matchen wir die Paten-Kinder mit Paten und Pateninnen, die gut zu ihnen passen. Also es melden sich vielleicht vier, fünf Leute, sind voll die Fans von der Metaebene. Und wenn die sich zufällig für die gleichen Podcasts, die kommen dann wahrscheinlich in eine Gruppe zusammen, sodass sie auch gleich eine Bezugsgruppe haben und kriegen dann einen Paten zugewiesen. Denn die Idee des Ganzen ist ja, dass wir uns selber überflüssig machen und die eigentlich uns gar nicht brauchen nach ein paar Stunden oder nach einem Tag. Und am besten mit ihrer eigenen Gruppe oder selber Freunde finden. Und das ist auch eigentlich so, wie es läuft. Also Leute kommen an und sind vielleicht ein bisschen eingeschüchtert oder haben aus den verschiedensten Gründen Angst vor dem großen Hacker-Kongress. Aber man muss das dann halt emotional als Pate verpacken, dass die dann Pflegel werden innerhalb kürzester Zeit und dich nie wieder melden.
Jetzt kann ich mir aber so sagen vorstellen, dass gerade das so ein Angebot ist, was auch so ein bisschen eine Anspruchshaltung generiert. Also dass dann Leute vielleicht kommen und sagen, ja so hier bin ich, jetzt unterhalte mich bitte und zeigt mir, wie das geht. Passiert sowas auch?
Ja, also es gibt solche Leute auch. Wir hatten dieses Mal ca. 130 Patenkinder, davon waren viele spontan erst bei uns, aber versuchen halt schon zu vermeiden, dass es als der große Touristenführer wahrgenommen wird auf dem Kongress, indem wir halt sagen, hey, ihr müsst euch anmelden und etwas über euch erzählen, damit wir euch jemandem zuweiten können, der oder die für euch passt. Aber wir hatten auch total viele Leute, die auf dem Kongress unserer As Family kamen. Wir hatten auch eine As Family auf dem Kongress. Zum Beispiel meinten sie, hey, Scheiße, ich bin gerade angekommen, ich hab keine Ahnung, was es hier ist und wo ich bin. Ich hab mich jetzt schon dreimal verlaufen. Auch für solche Leute sind sie da. Erfreulicherweise hat die As Family sich auch nach einer Zeit selber getragen, weil die Tatenkinder auch selber dann solche Leute durch ein Hallo gesagt haben. Und irgendwann haben sie aufgehört zu sagen, gibst du Fiona? Sondern haben dann selber gesagt, hey, was ist los? Kann man dir helfen? Ich führ dich rum. Und dann wird auch denen Leuten geholfen. Und es kommen auch Leute mit ganz verschiedenen Bedürfnissen zu uns hin.
Und das werdet ihr das nächste Jahr wieder machen, dann irgendwie noch in Größe, bis der ganze Kongress voller Paten- und Patenkinder ist? Oder wie wird das in Zukunft laufen?
Das ist nicht das Ziel. Also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass dieses Mal noch mehr Patenkinder von einem netten Kongress mitmachen werden. Sie brauchen wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen Unterstützung im Order-Team, damit die Arbeit ein bisschen besser verteilt wird. Aber ich glaube, die Chaos-Paten haben so verschiedene Effekte. Und ich glaube, einer davon ist, dass wir diese Lücke zwischen dem, was Leute erwarten und was sie tatsächlich erwartet, ein bisschen schließen können. Denn wir uns schreien ja echt so über 100 Leute mit ihren Ängsten und warum sie jetzt die Chaos-Paten kontaktieren und warum sie jemanden brauchen. Und es ist schon eine der schönsten, aber auch erstaunlichsten Erkenntnisse sicherlich, dass es einen Riesenunterschied gibt zwischen dem, was Leute befürchten und was sie dann wirklich auf den Kongress erleben. Na die sagen halt, naja, ich bin vielleicht eine junge Frau, ich bin gar keine richtige Hackerin oder ich kenne auch niemanden, sind bestimmt alle unfreundlich, hat dann aber innerhalb kürzester Zeit viele tolle neue Freunde gefunden und ganz viel gelernt. Und man merkt halt so, dass der Beruf des Kongresses ihm vielleicht ein bisschen hinterherhängt oder dem, was einen tatsächlich erwartet. Und wir versuchen da halt zu kommunizieren, es ist überhaupt nicht so schlimm, habt Mut, sprecht Leute an und vielleicht kann man ja in zwei, drei Jahren auf die Chaos-Partynen verzichten, weil die Leute ihre Ängste verlieren, die sicherlich zum großen Teil auch durch mediale Redner-Situationen vielleicht kommen.
An dem Ruf arbeiten wir mit dieser Sendung ja auch.
Genau, wir arbeiten dran.
Also ich kann die Chaos-Partyn nur empfehlen. Nee, warte, egal. Fiona, vielen Dank und viel Glück und Spaß noch weiterhin mit den Chaos-Partynen.
Ja, danke.
Sendung fast vorbei, der Kongress ist schon mitten im Schwange. Das könnte man so sagen. Dann wurde ja immer wieder von den sogenannten Assemblies geredet. Es gibt ja vom Kongress Vorträge, die gehalten werden. Und dann gibt es dieses riesige Kongresszentrum, das ist auch irgendwie ausgeschmückt. Dann gibt es auch eine Bar und so was. Und dann gibt es halt noch die Assemblies. Was das ist, wie man die organisiert. Und was da passiert ist, wird jetzt Martin erklären. Hallo und guten Abend. Ja, das ist... Ja, ist natürlich die Frage, was macht man in solchen Fällen, vom Kongress, wenn unvorhergesehene Dinge passiert? Ist euch da schon mal was untergekommen?
Nee, immer alles super durchgeplant.
Das lügst du doch.
Und das Tolle ist, wir haben ja ganz tolle Saalengel und Saalkoordinatoren, die stellen sich dann da hin und machen erstmal ein bisschen Unterhaltung. Also langweilig.
Die Heralde. Die Heralde, Entschuldigung. Es gibt einen coolen Vortrag, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, worum es ging. Auf jeden Fall hat der irgendwie auch so einen Linux und hat mit dem Beamer nicht klarkommen. Da springt der Herald auf die Bühne und macht halt erstmal die Show. Also wenn du halt als Speaker vorne bist und deine Folien nicht funktionieren, dann bist du halt total aufgeschmissen. Das heißt, du versuchst im ersten Moment irgendwie noch das Publikum zu unterhalten, dabei so die Sachen zu fixen, was halt nicht geht. Und da ist dann halt irgendwie so der Herald irgendwie reinkommen, hat irgendwie so die Angst rausgenommen oder die Spannung rausgenommen, hat irgendwie sich mit dem Publikum unterhalten, so ein bisschen lustig erzählt und irgendwie in der Zwischenzeit konnte der Speaker dann halt irgendwie in Ruhe seine Folien irgendwie fixen.
Ja, weiter.
Er hat also quasi innerhalb dieser ganzen Zeit irgendwie eine Story erzählt, wie er irgendwie einen Gegenstand von New York über Österreich nach Berlin geschafft hat, hat das quasi in drei Kapitel unterteilt und das wäre quasi alle Talks, wo er Herald war und irgendwelche Probleme gefixt werden mussten, hintereinander hört, was man übrigens auch auf MediaCCC.de nachgucken kann. Dann kann man diese Geschichte zusammenkriegen.
Wir versuchen es nochmal mit Martin. Martin, bist du da? Wir wollten auch ganz kurz von dir wissen, was Assemblies sind und was man da so erleben kann.
Ja, also der Starbucks hatte das ja schon erwähnt, dass man das Konzept von den Villages, also dass sich die ganzen Gruppen, die irgendwie zu dem Funk-Gast fahren, sich so ein bisschen organisieren und dann Platz kriegen, wo sie sich dann auch so ein bisschen breit machen können. Es gibt ja dann auch irgendwie einen Haufen Leute, die dann recht viel Technik dabei haben. Das geht dann irgendwie über 3D-Drucker bis Splashy-Maschinen bis Löt-Equipment und so weiter.
Textilsticker, eine TARDIS.
Und was ist da deine Aufgabe gewesen?
Es sind inzwischen relativ viele Gruppen. Wir hatten über 200, die sich registriert haben. Vorher haben sie gesagt, wir würden gern kommen. Wir haben irgendwie einen Haufen Equipment dabei. Viele von ihnen hatten dann auch irgendwelche Spezialeinforderungen, dass sie gesagt haben, wir brauchen ein bisschen Strom, so 32 Ampere. Stahlstrom an unserem Platz wäre irgendwie cool. Wir brauchen schnelles Internet, also nicht so ein Gigabyte, sondern irgendwie so 10 Gigabyte. Das ist dann eher schon so Standard. Aber dann gibt es dann meistens auch noch welche mit irgendwelchen Spezialeinforderungen. Das Ganze irgendwie zu managen und gucken, dass die Leute das kriegen, was sie brauchen. Und die Leute sinnvoll im Gebäude verteilen. Das ist für die Aufgabe von dem Assembly-Team, wo ich dabei war.
Also es gibt ja erstmal die Wiki-Seite, wo sich die Assemblies eintragen, wo halt steht, wie viele Leute sie mitbringen, wie viel Platz sie brauchen, was für Besonderheiten es gibt. Und dann gibt es ja praktisch so eine Außer- bzw. eine Zusammengruppierung. Erzähl doch mal, wie dieser Prozess läuft.
Also genau, die tragen sich im Wiki ein. Da schreiben sie dann auch so ein bisschen, was sie machen, was sie vorhaben, was sie mitbringen. Und dann haben wir probiert, vor allem nachdem es jetzt zwischen so viele sind, die so ein bisschen zu gruppieren. Beziehungsweise mal nachzufragen, wenn wir uns unklar haben, was wir dabei haben, wo wir sie ein bisschen einfertieren können. Dann haben wir so 15, 20 Cluster gebildet und probiert, die halt zusammensetzen, sodass die ganzen Leute, die mit 3D-Druckern basteln, an einer Ecke sitzen, die ganzen Leute, die Software entwickeln, die Leute, die Politik machen, in einer Ecke. Dass da auch ein Austausch zwischen den ganzen Gruppen noch ein bisschen mehr gefördert wird.
Das ist ja ein viel komplexeres System. Das ist ja ähnlich, wie wenn du einen Stundenplan machen musst. Es gibt Leute, die gern ruhig sitzen und hell. Dann gibt es Leute, die gern dunkel sitzen, aber ruhig Musik vertragen. Dann gibt es Gruppen, die mit anderen Gruppen zusammensitzen, aber auf keinen Fall mit der Gruppe zusammensitzen wollen.
Das ist wie eine Hochzeitsgesellschaft, die mal aussteigen muss. Aber Tante Frieda darf nicht gegen Onkel Erna sitzen, sonst bewerfen die sich wieder.
Genau so ist das wirklich.
Es gab schon Vorschläge von denen, wo ihr gesagt habt, nein, mit radioaktiven Stoffen rumzuspielen ist nicht so eine coole Idee.
Ja, es gibt immer noch ein paar Spezialisten, die dabei sind. Die Food Hanging Base möchte natürlich dann auch ein bisschen kochen. Wenn man das konkret drum anguckt, dann ist es auf der einen Seite ein paar Kette, auf der anderen Seite ist es Teppich. Das ist beides nicht das, was man als Boden haben will, wenn Leute kochen und mit Wasser und Töpfen arbeiten.
Und überall sind wahrscheinlich Rauchmelder?
Genau, die Rauchmelder haben wir auch nicht vergessen. Die haben auch was dagegen, wenn da zu viel Zeug in der Luft ist. Oder Gruppen, die dann kommen und sagen, wir haben irgendwie so ein 3D-Troger dabei, so 1, 50 x 1, 50 Meter, für den brauchen wir dann auch irgendwie Platz.
Was ich gehört habe von den, wenn ich so Leute aus meinem Freundeskreis gemacht habe, die beliebtesten Dinge, die da ausgerührt wurden, waren der Cocktail-Bot und die Coffee Nerds. Was war deine Lieblings-Assembly?
Die Frage ist, wer hat am wenigsten Stress gemacht?
Noch an dich als letzter auch noch die Frage, warum macht man sowas? Beim Third haben wir gelernt, das ist nicht dieses, wir spielen mit Technik rum, das ist cool, sondern es ist tatsächlich, in einem Umfeld zu arbeiten, was man sonst auch macht, aber ganz anders, viel entspannter, viel relaxter. Warum gibt man sich den Orga-Stress, um sozusagen ganz viele wildgewordene Hühner unter einen Hut zu bekommen?
Na, die ganzen wildgewordenen Hühner sind dann meistens auch relativ interessant, weil sie halt irgendwelche Themen in Spezialgebieten im Land echt viele Leute kennen. Ja, das ist halt so ein großer Kommunikations-Task. Das ist eigentlich auch mal ganz nett.
Also Martin macht ja nicht nur die Assembly-Platzierung, sondern ist irgendwie auch so derjenige, der im Haus so für die Tische und Stühle fand. Also wenn du halt so gesagt hast, da unten steht zu viel Tische oder irgendwie, wir brauchen auch Tische, dann gehst du halt auch zu Martin.
Wie lange brauchst du, um dich davon zu erholen nach dem Kongress? Alles klar, Martin organisiert die Assemblies, sind doch so kleine extra Sachen, wo Leute Dinge tun. Martin, vielen Dank und viel Spaß auch weiterhin. So, jetzt haben wir uns fast zwei Stunden damit beschäftigt, wie man eigentlich so einen Chaos Communication Congress organisiert. Was ich jetzt so als Bottomline mitnehme, ist so, okay, ihr macht das zwar alles selber und es ist unbezahlt und man könnte es theoretisch auch irgendwie aus dem Boden stampfen, aber da ist schon was herangewachsen über die Jahre, was man jetzt mal nicht so einfach nachmacht, würde ich mal vermuten.
Also, nicht in der Größe.
Es gibt viele Teams, die einfach auch unabhängig den Kram machen, das POG-Team zum Beispiel hat eine kleine Firma auch ausgegründet und macht jetzt auch andere Großveranstaltungen, Decktelefone, das heißt, wenn man ähnliche Sendungsbewusstsein hat und so eine Veranstaltung wuppen möchte, dann kann man auch auf viel von den Teams und viel von der Software zugreifen, die wir da schon noch oben liegen haben. Wahrscheinlich in genau der Größenordnung wird man es nicht hinbekommen, aber so viele Besucher muss man erstmal aktivieren.
Ja, aber würdet ihr tatsächlich sagen, weil der Gedanke vom Chaos Computer Club ist ja immer irgendwo auch machen, also dieses Sagen, ich möchte mich jetzt hinsetzen und nicht für 10.000, aber keine Ahnung, für 100 oder vielleicht auch nur für 50 Leute so was auf die Beine stellen.
Das muss man eine Angst vorhaben? Ich würde schon sagen ja, weil diese Nerd-Kultur ist halt was Besonderes. Also ein gutes Beispiel dafür, wie dieses wir brauchen Hilfe und Leute machen mit, war irgendwie bei mir am dritten Tag. Wir haben irgendwie die total unsinnige Idee gehabt, die Garderobe von einem Ende des Hauses zum anderen Ende des Hauses zu verlegen.
Warum?
Mitten in der Nacht, also um 5 Uhr nachts. Ich bin halt einfach zu Leuten, die dort noch gehackt haben, hab gesagt, Jungs, wir haben jetzt hier eine Stunde Scheißaufgaben, habt ihr Bock mitzuhelfen? Es sind alle aufgestanden. Wir waren dann zum Schluss mit 20, 30 Leuten, die Koffer durch die Gegend gefahren haben. Und das ist halt wirklich das Coole. Nicht nur in der Organisationsstruktur finden sich Leute, die mitmachen und die selber Sachen organisieren, sondern du kannst auch einfach zu random people hingehen und sagen, wir brauchen Hilfe. Und sie sind einfach in der Regel sofort mit dabei und helfen dir, wo es geht.
Ich sag dir, wenn du es vorlebst, folgen die Leute.
Okay, zwei Stunden Chaosradio, zwei Stunden über eine Gohaka-Großveranstaltung, wie man sie organisiert. Falls ihr jetzt nicht selber eine machen wollt, wollt ihr vielleicht...
Aber wir wollen selber eine machen. Im Sommer. Wir müssen noch das Camp ankündigen. Dieses Jahr, genauso wie vor vier Jahren, vor acht Jahren, vor zwölf Jahren und vor 16 Jahren, gibt es dieses Jahr wieder das Chaos Communication Camp. Und zwar vom...
13. bis 17.
August. Na, nicht mehr ganz so in der Nähe von Berlin. Also wir sind jetzt ein bisschen weiter nach Norden gegangen.
Zwischen zwei Autobahnen. Also ziemlich genau zwischen zwei Autobahnen an der Grenze zu Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Ist in einer alten Ziegelei. Und die Umgebung ist sehr schön. Also anders als die letzten Jahre, wo wir immer so ein bisschen auf dem Flughafen waren, wo das Wasser gefiltert ist, gibt es diesmal Wasser und Idylle. Und es verspricht auf jeden Fall eine sehr schöne Veranstaltung zu werden. Also wer noch nicht auf dem Camp war oder noch nicht auf dem Kongress war, sollte das auf jeden Fall ins Auge fassen, das zu tun. Und selbst wer schon da war, also wer da war, wird auf jeden Fall hinkommen.
Da kann man mit Familie, da kann man mit ohne Familie einfach Zelt schnappen, hinwerfen. Gibt wahrscheinlich Internet, gibt Strom, gibt sogar Hygiene inzwischen.
Verrückt, das teilt weniger zu tun.
Da gibt es halt drei Sien, die noch funktionieren.
Also das ist halt wirklich irgendwie der Congress nochmal potenziert. Also nicht von der Anzahl der Leute, aber vom Coolheitsfaktor. Also weil du halt einfach auf dem Acker, also es wird halt dort auch Netzwerk geben, es gibt dort auch WLAN, es gibt halt die ganzen Gruppen, die wir jetzt aufgezählt haben, gibt es dort auch wieder, aber in einer viel extremeren Art und Weise, weil du halt einfach die Sachen auf dem Acker machen musst.
Okay, also eine Hacker Großteilanschaltung auf dem Acker, ich bin gespannt. Erdgeist, Danimo und Starbuck, vielen Dank fürs hier sein und mal erklären, wie das alles so geht. Ihr könnt diese Sendung, wenn ihr noch nicht alles mitbekommen habt, noch als Podcast hören, erscheint im Laufe der Nacht auf fritz.de, später dann irgendwann auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Wenn ihr Fragen habt, stellt sie gerne, könnt eine Mail schreiben an chaosradio.ccc.de, es gibt auch einen Twitter-Account, ihr seid also versorgt. Vielen Dank euch fürs Zuhören und auch für die Geschichten, die uns teilweise hier erzählt habt. Ich sage nur noch eine Sache, mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Lasst uns nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.